And boom,
we're live.
What's up?
Suddenly like pressure when you said it just like chilling here for a minute.
I should take these off as well.
You guys don't have mon Jamie and let us know if you can't hear us.
So a admin and Rhonda,
welcome.
What's up?
Welcome to uh,
humble abode.
I like the new place.
It's been a minute.
Yeah,
it's been a while.
The last time we did a podcast you weren't even in the UFC yet.
I hadn't even fought for us going to fight for the district,
for his title the first time they came on.
Is that really that long ago.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I got you the Cognac.
It's mad at Jamie.
It's good.
We're good.
That's right.
Armenian Cognac.
It's fucked up.
You guys are a very interesting combination.
Before this even got started,
I have to tell her buddy Edmunds over here.
Rhonda is over here.
Get over here.
Get closer.
He can't be that far from me.
I don't know why.
It's crazy.
All the hit him at all times.
Is that what it is?
Like my distance with him at all times.
What do you want to touch them?
You want them right there?
You guys are very close.
You have a very unusual relationship.
It wasn't always like that though.
No,
it was very like Clint Eastwood,
Hilary Swank in million dollar baby status.
I was like very good chicken or the gym.
Would all the Armenian guys stay away from me?
You know
I love Armenians.
One of the reasons why I love Armenians cause they're unapologetically masculine
ditch,
very few unapologetically masculine cultures left in America.
Like people are like apologizing for being men and Armenians don't play that
Shit.
This is a,
it's a fun culture that's very interesting masculine but they are not afraid to
accessorize
every like I'm not a shiny shit is always like dissolved because of designer
Cologne,
you know?
No socks now.
That's the thing.
Now they wear the shoes.
No socks.
They're very fashionable.
They had to get me to actually start like cleaning up a little bit.
Really?
Yeah.
It was the reverse.
Like they had to like,
they had to make me over when I first started coming.
So what was their advice?
Um,
well I used to be that I had this car,
the Fonda was my Honda and it had one working window and no air conditioning.
So I would just sweat all the way home.
So I would just put on my same,
like my clothes I came in with when they're like no shower.
I would just throw it on still sweating,
jump in my car cause I would just want to let homeless the point and Edmunds,
first word of advice was he made me shower before I got in the car.
Even if I would set all the way home and have the shower again,
that was like,
he was like,
no,
not on the job.
And I know you're know you're a very good girl.
And
she went away.
Like I taught him English.
You speak to high school?
Yeah.
But during the classes like Armenian,
Armenian kids have to grow up.
You know,
the parents loved
it because they go to school,
speak English and the parents would bring them to the gym after school programs
and they would want their kids to speak Armenian so they won't forget where
they're from.
You know?
And so teaching for like 10 years,
every day,
four to 10 I was like only speaking Armenian and then I like couldn't speak
well.
Like I was like,
well what's happening here?
I forgot my English or something.
Yeah,
they brought it back.
He was the one too after.
I like want a couple of fights.
It was like a no,
maybe you should wear look that gets a little pretty some time.
Put some,
make
you bad thing and like,
yeah that was all like,
like hell.
Trying to get me to the girly.
I've a little bit cause yeah,
I was a lot grungier when I first started coming to the show.
That's such a,
you're such a fascinating contradiction in that way because when you clean up,
you know you're beautiful,
you clean up your a 10 but you're,
you're,
you don't give a fuck
around.
Like putting like,
you know,
we're going all out all the time because then you can't step it up when it's
time to step it up.
Like,
oh I want to be able to have like my,
she's all that like unveiling moment whenever I feel like it.
Oh I see.
And so some girl,
the other girls didn't do it the other way.
Like they're oh they,
they literally can't not be made up when they leave the house.
They fucking panic.
I understand that.
Like I like my face.
You have a beautiful face.
I'm saying like I should spend my time like you know,
paranoid to show people in the actual face looks like.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing with women.
We've,
with the,
our culture is decided that women have to have like unusual,
unnatural colors over their eyes.
Your lips have to like,
this is where I suck the dirt.
So happening right here,
me don't you want to get in there.
How do you see like those contouring videos and stuff like that or like what is
that?
You have to find these contouring things where it starts with a girl with her
face plane and they do all this contour stuff to them and like they're an
entirely different person by the end of it.
That's so weird.
Yeah.
I saw like this one thing,
I dunno,
it was like an Instagram for so who knows if it wasn't even true,
but some,
some guy sued his wife after they were married because he never saw her without
makeup.
She was totally busted without it.
It doesn't make it.
There was one about a Chinese guy who sued his wife because she had a gang of
plastic surgery in the kids came out ugly.
But I don't think that was really there.
I think,
you know,
opened my eyes.
Not a lot like whenever like I see people like it's like like a good looking
couple,
but they got butt ugly kids that,
you know,
it's just like the work done.
You know,
you can't,
you can't get your genetics lifted.
Yeah.
It is a weird thing were like Koreans have like a real issue in their culture
where they get their eyes.
It's so common that a lot of girls,
like there's very few natural eyes left.
It's like everyone gets their eyes done.
It's like shooting.
They graduate,
they get their eyes change.
Koreans have naturally like a thin opening for their eye.
Will they get there?
Like eyelids,
they get surgery done and their eyes
are poker and how all that's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
Jamie,
pull it up so he could,
she,
you guys can see it
strict,
but it's extremely common.
Like as common is probably more common than braces are here.
Like look what's going on.
It's men.
WHOA character.
Look at those eyes.
Look at that.
Okay.
Look at those two.
Well,
one of them looks like she's eight.
That's not fair.
But it's,
it's a very,
very,
very common procedure over there to the point where,
so
these girls,
she's in the corners of her eyes.
It looks like it does it yet.
Oh
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
that's exactly what it is.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
extremely.
Extremely common.
They do all sorts of other weird shit too.
Like they put Chin implants in them.
Look at that girl,
had her chin shaved down.
Like,
okay,
there's perfect.
The one on the left that looks like big foot silver sister and the one on the
right is a 10 so like what happened there?
Well,
they shaved her down.
They uh,
wow.
She looks like a Gnocchi sister.
That's what she looks like.
Oh,
Antonio Enoki the guy who fought Muhammad Ali.
That's what she looks like,
right?
Not,
not in the,
it's a bad thing.
Look,
they fixed it.
So great.
Now congratulations.
I bet that girl went on a dick ramp.
Paige after she got that done.
I should probably do,
you know,
because before everyone else like not really interested and then Bam,
the girl on the right.
Holy Shit.
It was
Leo swarm,
you know?
But that's super common.
Wow.
It's weird.
It's weird because it's,
it's not in your DNA and so like your children are going to have to deal with
the same issues like your whatever weird jaw structure thing.
No structure thing that you're going to get fixed with a doctor.
I'm going to get your kids snip too.
You know,
I don't know.
I just,
I'm not like a big cosmetic surgery type of person,
you know that is your face and like,
yeah,
cool with it.
Yeah.
But what if you have like some goofy,
you know like there was a girl I went to school with in high school.
She had a big crazy knows she's a nice girl but it was like crazy like wicked
witch of the West type shit.
She had like a crazy hump and then she got it removed.
She got her nose fixed and all of a sudden she was hot as fuck.
And everybody was like,
what happened as Susan like damn this is,
it's weird.
It's like this way and people,
there's nothing wrong with,
I'm like the chick from dirty dancing.
I was absolutely gorgeous.
You've got her nose dive.
Then it was like no one could recognize her.
She never could get a part again.
That's weird because you become famous for that look.
And then like the other girl who did that recent Renee Zellweger,
she did it recently.
She's unrecognizable.
Yeah,
she is gorgeous.
I think that it feels like a line like you know,
if you have like a cleft lip or something like wrong with you,
you know go,
you know,
go for it.
But like if you just self conscious you know about something and then
you know,
maybe you should just accept it that that's how he look.
You know,
I think the stars if they're on TV the time,
you know
already people get used to that look so they shouldn't be that worried about it.
Well it's also like if you're on television,
that's your currency.
Like your currency is your appearance,
you know,
and and just re relinquishing any aspect of that.
They think like the whole reason they got there is because there looks like
there's a lot of people that believe that.
But I mean like when you're a kid,
you went to area high school,
your teenager,
you're going to hate everything pretty much about yourself for awhile.
You know,
you're like,
Oh God,
yeah,
you're suddenly super self conscious.
But all of that,
and if it's like so common,
easily accessible,
people are going to end up getting so much work done when they're kids and
they're just being going through that stage when you know you should at least
wait until you're like pass 30 and you're like,
you know,
you've had a good three decades of not being happy with how that looks,
then okay fine,
go for it.
But if you're a teenager and you're like,
oh my God,
my finance and has big boobs and I want to get implants,
like,
no,
don't do it.
Okay,
you're 18 you'll,
you'll get over it,
you'll,
you'll accept that.
You know,
it'd be a titty committee is pretty cool,
but you are,
you're,
you're doing something right now with this whole,
don't be a do nothing bitch thing.
Are you aware of like how big this movement,
and I tweeted about it the other day that I was,
I forgot where I was,
but these two girls were arguing about the merits,
pros and cons of being a do nothing bitch.
And it was completely,
it was all after your fight.
And it was this completely brought on by you.
Like some girls were like,
well listen,
you know,
like I don't like to fucking work,
I don't want,
I don't want to,
you know,
what's wrong with being a do nothing bitch.
And the other girl was like,
no,
she's fucking right.
You know,
like too many girls are out there doing his,
he just contributed nothing to society like you are you like all you do is
consume.
If you are do nothing,
bitch,
all you do is spend somebody else's money and try to look pretty.
Like that's all you do is you use stuff up,
you use up resources and you give nothing.
And so you're a pretty much a drain on society.
That's what I think they,
they don't think it that way.
They think what they are is something that all of these men want to fuck low.
So in,
in working really hard to attain this,
this appearance and all these men want to fuck that.
Uh,
the what they are,
they've,
they've created capital.
They've created like a,
a need for this brought up to think that it wasn't your mission in life to be
happy.
It was your mission in life to leave the world better than how you found it.
And by being a comeback at,
you're not going to do that.
It's not your mission in life.
I guess I invented that.
No,
I did it.
That's a fascinating thing to say that it's not your mission in life to be
happy.
So,
but what's the point in leaving the world better?
If no one's happy,
if everybody follows that same principle,
the world just keeps getting better and better and everybody's miserable as
fuck.
I think your,
your happiness,
it's supposed to be a byproduct of actually living a fulfilling life.
You know,
instead of just trying to,
you know,
if I tried to get drunk and party every day and get as happy as I possibly could
every day,
you know,
I'm going to live at a really unfulfilling life and die unhappy,
but does that,
where happiness comes from,
like the reality of happiness is happiness comes in,
at least in my feeling,
it comes from achieving goals and conquering whatever weird shit you don't like
about yourself.
Like whatever weird,
uh,
discipline issues you might have or behavior issues you might have and
accomplishing goals.
Like there's something about setting goals,
working hard on something and accomplishing those things.
It creates a real happiness.
The other,
the other kind of happened has,
comes from family and friends and loved ones.
That's,
that's the other happiness.
I mean,
I,
I think it's also about not being selfish and thinking about your kids too,
because we could all be as happy as possible.
You know,
this generation burn every resource we have and all of our kids are going to
starve,
you know,
and some post apocalyptic world because everybody before I was just trying to be
happy,
you know,
and like that's not really a good way to live either.
Yeah.
I like,
I want my,
I want to know that my kids are going to be all right and they're live in
growing up in a better world than I did.
That's gonna make me happier than knowing that I had a great time and good luck
kitties.
So the way you do that is by telling chicks and not be a good nut.
Don't be a do nothing bitch.
And definitely don't want my kids to be
well I don't think that they will be.
It'll be a real issue growing up in the rousy household being your mom wrote a
fucking hilarious blog the other day about sycophants,
you know,
did you read that?
My mom is,
she's a blog master.
She's a character.
If you know,
he'd be like,
you really know my mother.
You understand?
Most of me cause she is like,
I need to get her in here.
Your mom is so powerful.
She's,
yeah she's,
there's some about your mom like just talking to her,
you go whoa,
this is a powerful woman.
Like she's got to think like I was so like laid back and chill and like,
you know my mom was like the really just really intense and then I realized this
in comparison to her,
I was really laid back and chill and I'm actually pretty intense.
I was surprised.
It was like,
you're so intense.
Like what are you talking about?
And that Schuelke who won.
It's all relative.
Hang out with my mom and be like,
whoa.
I'm like,
I don't know how you are as chill as you are.
The standards are set so high in your house that just being like what you
thought was chill in your house.
Everybody else was like,
whoa.
I mean like I was like the black sheep loser in my house for like a long time.
Cause you were a loser.
Yeah.
Cause everybody else is like bachelor's and master's degrees and they're like,
you know,
like average was below like below average.
Exceptional was average in our family.
The rule was you could pick anything you wanted to do in the world but you just
had to be the best in the world at it.
Just like you don't,
you don't have to pick one specific thing,
but you just have to be the best in the world at it.
Fuck,
that's a lot of pressure.
Yeah.
When you're a kid.
But you know what,
now I'm happy for it because now I'm in high pressure situations all the time
and I can totally deal with it.
I mean now I'm live on the Joe Rogan and I'm sure my
heart rate is perfectly fine.
Well this is a very low pressure situation to Brazil.
Well I'm sure it was some people listening right now if they got on,
you know they'd have a hard time relaxing.
Like my first time that I came on your show,
I was a little bit like amped up because I would watch it all the time and I was
a fan.
Like I would go to training,
I would come home and I would make,
I got to the point where I could afford trader Joe's at that point.
So I was like made myself a sandwich at trader Joe's and I would like sit and
eat my sandwich and listened to you every day.
Well,
if I remember correctly,
we might have been medicated at the time as well.
Yeah,
it might've been some plant burning going on.
Speaking of Brazil,
like dad experience,
to me that was one of the strangest experiences of all my years of calling
fights.
It was one of the strangest experiences because it had sort of transcended just
fighting.
It had gotten into this weird cultural place.
Like when we first of all went there,
um,
it was the first time I sat in the audience for Whanau never sat in the audience
for women before.
But when we got there,
they had some dude that was a Brazilian guy that was going to do the weigh ins
because they wanted it to be in Portuguese.
So,
uh,
I sat down in the front row and I got to watch him.
One of the freakiest things about it was it was the first time ever to all the
fights that I've ever called in Brazil where the Brazilian got booed and the
American gut cheered and I was like,
this is a where we've hit some weird tipping point here.
And I was kind of a,
it was a strange to observe that.
I was like,
when you went on stage,
they were cheering you and you know,
she's like got the Brazilian flag and she's getting fucking crazy and she's
tried to get everybody on her side and they were like,
hmm,
that's not,
we're here for,
we're here for the Ronda Rousey show.
She's trying really hard to pull that angle.
She bought the resilient flag everywhere.
She flew with it and the plains,
you've got the plane with it.
I mean,
I'm sure she went to the bathroom with it.
Like I did never saw her without that flag.
But I mean,
they throw it on the ground when you're walking in and her brother like takes
the flag and throws it at my face when I'm walking in and I'm like,
okay,
it's cool for you to be patriotic and proud of your country,
but you're like,
you don't throw your flag on the ground.
Yeah.
That's disrespectful to your country.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh my God.
So headwinds,
not going to say this,
but like,
okay,
this her brother,
the guy with like her,
she had a brother who was like blue hair.
I don't know,
like he was going to be shit on Instagram for like a month.
He was harassing Edmund all over his Instagram.
Right.
And causing Edwin's like,
just you wait,
when I get done with this,
when you beat her ass,
I'm going to buy,
I didn't have it that wanting to tell him.
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
So yeah,
cause that's at a mistake.
He like gets riled up.
And,
uh,
so,
um,
then we get there and she,
he's like wearing like these,
these pink shirts and he was outside when we're leaving the bus and being like,
you know,
fuck you Dah Dah and like a pink shirt.
And I'm like,
aw,
look at you like,
you know,
saying fucking pink.
That's cute.
So then I'm walking out,
the guy throws the Brazilian flag on my face,
Edmond almost like start something right then,
but I'm about to walk out of the,
I could tell that he's like restraining himself.
He's like,
he's almost just like,
I'm going to see you later kind of thing and like cuts it off,
which I appreciate that self control at the moment.
Yeah.
So if you watch in the background,
I put like that don't cry like clip on my Instagram.
Right.
If you look in the background,
her face hits the mat.
Edelman does not celebrate.
The first thing he does is he turns around and runs straight at that dude.
Her brother,
he doesn't go Yay.
It was almost like he was sitting there the whole time waiting for me to knock
around just so he could go and give this guy shit.
It wasn't like he was waiting for me and for wind,
so it can be happy.
You'd be like,
hurry up.
Not just my job.
I gotta go get after this fucking guy.
He's mine sites.
I'm still talking to watch over and over.
Edmund goes off the chair,
runs straight to the dude,
like not even,
you couldn't even smile.
It was whole happiest watch over and over and over do this.
And you see like the little gold drowsy,
like balancing away and he's like running up the fans.
Brazilian.
Yeah.
Fans that loves around there.
Right.
You saw it and their whole family just comes to all the fights and he has,
he's literally standing like right behind that dude.
And he has it recorded.
So they gave me through his phone,
you know,
he gave it to me.
Did you see the flag?
He gets it and throws it on.
I'm like,
you stupid.
Fuck.
Keep your,
you know,
it's your country's flag.
I do.
What happened afterward though,
I only saw you running away towards him.
Like what happened when you got on it?
I want it to grab him at,
went in and everybody helped me back called the security that holds the whole
event was so intense when she,
when she face planted right on the straight outta Compton.
Oh my God.
What was that meme
things afterward in data showed it to me.
I'm like,
ah,
you stood over insert and said don't cry.
Well cause that's what she was saying in the way,
and she's in my face going,
I those guys like she was before,
she knows y'all thing.
He's at me and I'd be like,
okay,
you know.
So at the Wayne,
she was speaking English to you.
She's,
that's what is the only thing she ever said to me in English was don't cry.
Don't cry over and over and over.
So then like right when I knocked her out and I like and get to fixed my short,
it sounds like,
oh yeah,
don't cry.
What makes you think of those things at that moment?
I don't know.
That's like the most like income came comprehensible moment ever.
That was an intense moment.
When you,
when you walked around the cage after he knocked her out.
It was,
it was one of,
I've seen guys when before,
I've seen women when before I've seen people win before but I never saw anybody
soak it all in the way.
You did when you walked around.
When she face planted you said don't cry and then you walked around like you
strutted around the octagon.
He likes strutted and looked around at all those people you like,
you took it all in,
you looked around you.
I was like,
wow,
this is a crazy moment.
Have you had it ever did?
That was the first time I did that actually.
Yeah.
I really like received it because usually it's just like,
okay,
I beat the person and then I have to not say anything stupid.
And then at the drug tests and do I medicals and then I had to do press
conference.
I don't say anything stupid again and then I can eat something and relax.
And that was the first time I took a moment
like to just like look at it all right.
Because I just probably thinking I wish I fuck her up one more time.
See what had happened to the crowd because it was interesting,
you know,
like,
cause I was getting booed a little coming in,
you know,
and um,
shot right the fuck up when you're knocked her out they cheer.
But when it turned,
yeah,
like I was,
I was looking into like,
I was this close to crying and you know,
like I'm a big time crier.
Like I was really,
really close.
Like,
ah,
that,
that one I'm going to remember forever.
It was definitely rocky four for sure.
Yeah.
Well it was also,
there was so much emotion attached to that because the shit that she had said
about suicide and connecting to your father and all that shit and,
and you know,
and knowing you as long as I've had and having daughters and it was,
it was so emotional for me.
That was the closest I've ever come to crime while I'm going to cry now and I
was interviewing somebody.
It's cause it was just,
it was so intense and it was also like I really knew that.
I was like seeing history.
It's like it's hard.
I know it's hard for you to probably talk about it because you're living it
right now,
but like you're,
you're in the middle of history.
Like what,
what,
what happened there and what's going on with you right now?
A gear or a part of some crazy movement right now.
It's not,
it's not just sport.
It's like you're this very unique example for other women.
Like that's never existed before.
There's never been a female combat sports athlete like you and when you went
down to Brazil,
not that girl out like that.
And then we're taking it all in.
It was,
it was so crazy.
I was so happy for you and it was so crazy at the same time.
It was just,
it was nuts.
The whole thing was,
it was such a strange moment.
There was a feeling in the air and there was a recognition of what was
happening.
That was very different for me than any other fight that I've ever called
before.
You know,
it was writing.
I think people just are starting to recognize how solid she is as a,
you know,
human being run.
Then every,
every opponent she's faced,
she keeps it very real,
very intelligent,
very professional.
And how an athlete should carry themselves.
A person should carry themselves.
If you watch all the fights,
you know,
Misha didn't behave from the beginning.
You know,
there's a lot of things from the beginning.
She didn't do what she was supposed to do.
Bringing her for it,
you know,
pushing during Wayans,
stuff like that.
It's great building up,
you know,
a fight.
It's normal,
it's the fight business.
But afterwards coin complaining to the Commission to find somebody when you
fight for living,
it's nonsense.
Why was she saying to find her to complain to the commission so they could touch
her purse to find her was,
she said that she put her forehead on mine our first way in and I pushed her
back and she said the commission should find me for headbutting her.
Yeah.
So basically they don't,
they're not real.
You don't do that.
You don't touch somebody's finances when a fighter yourself,
you know what I mean?
Not,
not in that way.
And every opponent,
how respectful she was against a cat,
you know,
even on the floor when Rhonda submitters said,
I'll give you another chance.
You know who those two quick and she's done.
She's done an amazing job,
man.
Everybody,
I think now after 10 fights,
12 fights,
13,
five,
they're starting to really realize that,
well,
I don't think we're really like,
I don't even think I'm going to really know what is going on right now or
realize what is going on right now until afterward,
you know,
until it's all done.
And,
um,
I could just try to do the best that I can in the moment,
but I don't really think that any of us really comprehend what's going on right
now until we're looking at it in hindsight.
And that's the kind of thing I think is kind of funny.
Just there's so many people that just live to hate me,
but when I'm gone they're going to miss me.
Really?
Are
You keep it real and you kick everybody's ass.
How are they ever going to have
like,
like a bad guy better than heath ledger as the joker?
Like you miss them.
You need like the joker is gone like you,
you're never going to have joker again.
I'm saying that like I am not the protagonist and the antagonist because the
protagonist just reacts.
They do nothing.
The whole storyline,
the whole,
everything that goes on is completely dependent on the antagonist.
I'm the one that's forcing everybody to do something.
And so like I like to think of myself as more of like the heel,
like the bad guy that you somehow like sometimes route for you can't help out a
little bit sometimes.
But sometimes you hate him,
but I think that the fact that you nixed emotions come out is one of the more
interesting things.
You know,
I'm not trying to have everyone like me.
I'm trying to have everybody care about what I'm doing.
When when you beat me Hsa and the audience was booing,
do remember that.
Yeah,
that Shit's all gone.
Like nobody,
nobody,
nobody remembers that.
It'll come back.
It'll come back because,
yeah,
because I wouldn't shake her hand
because it would,
it was a t entirely dis and genuine gesture for her to offer a handshake because
she never would have offered a handshake if she wasn't being watched by millions
of people.
And I wouldn't have shook her hand if we were alone in the room where we had
millions of people watching.
And the fact that I'm not going to play to the crowd for fee like to have the
light would've been so easy.
You just shake your hand,
have everybody cheer.
But I felt like it would have been dishonest.
And you know,
honesty pays,
but it pays very slowly and it doesn't pay very consistently.
Do you think that she was being honest when she shook her head?
Is it possible that she was being honest when she went to shake your hand?
Is it possible that all the anxiety and all the,
all,
all the animosity that she had went away when you guys fought?
No,
not at all.
Not Possible.
She insulted and really did some very shady backhanded,
you know,
backstage things to people that really love and care about without apologizing.
I didn't see his older.
Yeah,
they didn't see or what,
like what kind of stuff?
Like,
um,
one example at the ultimate fighter,
Chris Bill is about to go out and fight and he's all warmed up.
He's ready to go and literally like two minutes before it goes out,
Dana walks in and goes,
you're assigned with that promotion.
And he's,
he's like,
what?
And he's like,
your other promoter just called like,
we're pulling you out of this fight,
all this stuff to the,
yeah.
And it's a closed set.
No one's supposed to even know that he's on the ultimate fighter.
And how would this other promoter even know that he was about to fight in two
minutes and who would benefit from that kind of timing and things like that.
Like he would say it to,
he said it to other people in the house,
so they knew and the other team knew that it was at that promoter.
But how would the promoter know to call right before he's about to walk out to
mess with them the most?
Yeah,
because of Misha,
because somebody tipped them off because it was timed.
It was pretty,
I don't believe in coincidences.
There's no way that that was a coincidence.
So he was signed with another promoter and I think like he,
he had a contract,
but like he hadn't fought in so long.
He was supposed to,
the contract are supposed to default if they hadn't had him fight within that
amount of time.
So he was out of it,
but it was like some sort of messy contract situation or whatever.
But um,
he like mentioned it to,
you know,
to the other kids and it got back to their team and,
and they called.
And,
um,
set this up so that they would call right at the exact time.
He's not to go out and try to get Chris Beall pulled out or at least mess with
him enough to like have him not be fresh when you went in.
And so you're pretty sure that that was me.
She's doing who else is,
would it be,
who else would benefit from that?
He's always had access to phones.
Was that the only thing [inaudible] that's true.
Who else would have access to a phone?
Right?
Yeah.
That's not the only thing.
That's one small example.
I of very many.
And,
and
do you know what?
I just don't even want to like get into it.
I was like moved on with my life.
I just not,
not keeping it real.
You know,
we had during that come in and say,
just leave,
you know,
promise me that everything will be normal and you guys won't be acting up and
you're more distant that and we said,
yeah we will.
And you know,
a promise is a promise.
You have to be respectful,
you know what?
And then the next day day do the same shit.
It's like they put like some count Chocula doll in there with uh,
with uh,
like a certificate to like get your eyebrows lacks it said Edmond on it.
Yeah.
The thing is I gave him,
the thing is I could give them my number,
they could always send me anywhere in the street,
you know,
and I told him that,
there's too many cameras.
Don't act like a little bitch in front of cameras.
You know,
you guys could do that cause you know you don't,
we round doesn't want me to step out of line and kick your fucking ass right
there.
There you going to take me out of there and you know,
I gotta
do this for all those kids,
you know,
but they don't understand shit like that.
So when a person doesn't,
sometimes you can't fucking,
well that's the thing,
like if someone is like purposely like trying to like backhanded work against
you do really,
really shady shit and then try to like play sweetheart to everybody else and
then they try to play sweetheart again.
I'm not going to trust you at all.
Why would you expect that and why?
It would be an insult.
All the people that I love that you insulted to shake your hand without an
apology to them anyway.
Did you like to in that show?
Because it seemed like you hated it.
It was one of the worst experiences I've ever like had to deal with.
What was horrible about it?
Just being around me.
She all the time,
no about being,
um,
felt like I was trapped in a situation because the kids needed me so I couldn't
leave,
you know,
so I mean I was,
I was kind of trapped.
They were like using the fact that I needed to be there for these kids so they
would treat it us however they wanted.
And I just felt like I'd never felt like that disrespected in my whole life.
And I had to sit and take it every day and I had to watch the people that I
really love and care about get disrespected every day.
And that was really hard that they were like putting up with it every day
because of me.
And I just felt really,
really responsible for everything.
But,
um,
my,
you know,
I just don't even,
I'm not even supposed to go on about it anymore.
I get in trouble every time that I taught you about cost.
My fighter who gives you trouble,
Dana,
Danny gets upset,
people get upset.
I think you could probably say whatever the fuck you want right about now.
If I was your manager,
I'd be like,
ah,
just let it go.
Let it out
for yourself everywhere.
Everybody knows how I feel about it.
But I'm saying that like,
you know,
because I,
I know the,
all those things happened,
the people watching don't,
all these things happened and it would be very easy to,
to,
to placate to whatever everybody else was seeing.
But I was going to stay at,
you know,
do what I felt was God on us,
right thing to do.
What should we not shake that hand?
And if I want to boost me it fine.
And there's going to be another situation where you know,
everybody else see something one way,
but it's really another way.
And I could either
prioritize my perception and image above everything and everyone and every moral
that I have or I could try and do the right thing and be honest and have people
hate me for it sometime.
Cause this is how it is.
If there's cameras,
might as well show everything what happened and people will understand what
really did happen.
Right,
right.
It was just common sense.
But then whenever you have cameras and sometimes you show something and then
don't show the other,
mm,
then name I,
you know,
people might think what the hell just happened?
Like my situation with Donaldson Holman,
that guy,
he's looking at me in the parking lot.
He's looking at me,
I'm looking at him like he's looking at me.
Then he turns around and says,
I said,
fucking buy.
man,
when you say buy,
you don't use the fucking weird fucking,
you know,
have some fucking manners.
You stupid.
You need it.
I'll teach you a fucking manners.
You don't,
you can't talk to me.
There's no way.
There's no cameras.
There's no way you could speak to me.
It's impossible.
I want to talk about it anymore.
Yeah.
And then,
and then he comes and then when I go at him,
cause he fucking gets on my nerves and there's the camera's all kinds of
bullshit.
Well,
those reality shows are very problematic when they edit things and they also
like to edit things out of context.
I will take the reaction to something else and put it on the one thing.
And that's why we did it was it was a lot of reaction shown without constant
what?
Yeah,
what caused them.
Yeah.
I didn't even,
you know,
I just,
I just want to put that whole part of my life,
like behind me,
not what we should have known.
Yeah.
You can't take six weeks and put it into an hour a week.
You just can't.
It just won't.
It won't be real.
And all the different interactions you have,
they just do their best to make it entertaining.
But there's this one moment where you guys,
one of the coaches challenges where you,
uh,
you beat her and you're hanging from a rope and you go,
fuck.
You was like,
God damn,
that girl's fire burns.
It didn't matter that you,
you wanted a win and say fuck you.
What I really wanted to do was I wanted to wait and say,
fuck you and I wanted my kid.
Yeah,
I'll go home at 1000 bucks.
Right.
That meant a lot to them and the fact that she didn't give a shit that,
that,
that money would have meant a lot to our kids and they all lost it because she
didn't,
you know,
like the fact that it didn't affect her at all.
I was like,
don't give a fuck about them.
I'd been crushed if I lost item in question.
If all those kids that really could use $1,000 didn't go home with $1,000,
you know,
because like,
man,
I love those guys.
I was just,
I just got to,
we've got a video of him thinking about that shows intelligence.
Yeah.
Not Thinking about after the fight,
when you're getting your fucking ass kicked me,
you know,
shake hands.
What the fuck you're fighting.
Yeah.
At that time,
her intensity,
the way she's fighting.
You sticking your hand after being like that and then people boring because of
that.
It makes no fucking sense.
Bu for other things also,
you know,
people will be smarter than that.
People love to boob winners.
There's something about,
and people that win and they don't win like that.
They're not good winners like me.
They don't,
they're,
they're still upset at the person they beat.
People have a real problem with that.
Oh my God,
this reminds me of like these stores is here,
but my mom when she is competing like back in the day,
I can only imagine man,
like yeah,
Sue's always pissed.
You get angry leftover.
That's what they is.
They used to say about her,
like her all teammates tell me like yeah,
she would walk on the mat and should be pissed off and she throws and to be the
crowd arm bar and then walk off.
Still pissed off an angry leftovers.
He was still angry and resolved nothing and uh,
oh my God.
Yeah,
that's what I'm telling you.
Like just,
I can only imagine if MMA was around when my mom was completed.
How many,
how many siblings do you have?
You have one semester.
Three,
six,
three sisters?
Yes.
Are they all crazy too?
Cause everybody crazy.
Everybody is their own brand of Casey.
Um,
who's the crate you the craziest,
first
of all?
The sisters?
Um,
well I don't think there's one like the most crazy.
I think we just really have our own different of crazy,
but I think
Julia,
my little sister is probably the least.
The least.
She has the most chill.
Like she was very calm.
Yeah.
Like when whenever we're at fights,
like all my sisters are all like,
oh,
they're so amped up.
And like,
you know,
my,
my sister Maria,
I remember at one 68 end up getting a Migraine,
like threw up.
My mom went to the bathroom to cry.
My sister,
Jennifer's like,
I'm never going into a fight again.
And George was like,
I knew she'd win
our,
yeah.
What was,
which one was 68.
Was that Sara Mcmann?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
But Jennifer did ended up,
she said she'd never come to a fight again when she came to Brazil because I was
like,
I'll take you guys.
I'll resorting after if you come into it,
you know,
it's like,
all right,
fine.
Does your little sister,
does she train?
Uh,
she is soccer.
She's like about to go to the college and he's just gonna get a soccer
scholarship.
No judo.
She did judo.
She won't like went up to purple belt but you know,
she wasn't really,
she is,
she's,
there's a different mentality between someone who does individual sports and
some of those team sports and she is very much like a team sport mentality.
I've even brought her to come and do our training with us a little bit and
whenever we have like a team workout,
she works a lot harder than if it's like individual.
Like she really wants to like,
I dunno,
she's got one of those things where that's,
that's her environment.
Like I need all the pressure to be on me all the time.
Whereas like some kids do better attention and pressure and attention.
Well you seem,
you seem to be uniquely qualified to handle it and uniquely qualified to handle
the,
the pressure that comes with,
with being famous too.
It's very weird like how you handle it.
Like even your perspective,
like what you said about like you can't,
they like you,
you know,
you don't even know what the fuck's going on while it's happening because it's,
it's going to take till it's over for you to like look back and kind of
understand it.
That's a very uniquely honest and perceptive view of what you're going through.
Well,
I mean I notice a lot of these girls like they,
they would like to win a UFC belt and have that respect,
but they're not about that life.
They don't want that life.
They don't want the attention and scrutiny and pressure and constant work and
all those things.
And then they don't want it.
They,
they,
they want one thing without the other,
but I don't,
you know,
but it all comes together and that's,
I think one thing that's kind of working against them is when they actually come
in to fight me,
they get a taste like a small taste of what that life is going to be like when
they're a contender because it is like way more attention,
way more.
That's when only one that went over that and once doing the bell is just doubled
every single time.
It's more and more and more and more and they know,
I don't think any of them would actually be happy with that lifestyle.
I don't think they really truly want it.
No,
everybody wants to win.
Everybody wants to be a winner.
Everybody wants to be famous.
But I don't think anybody knows other than you.
Like you have to be there to know what that is like.
I see it from the outside
and it's,
it looks mind boggling.
The amount of pressure,
the media obligations,
the media obligations alone,
which is something nobody considers.
But if you go on youtube or you go on the Internet and look at all the different
interviews that you do up to a fight or any of the world champions do up to a
fight,
it's fucking staggering.
I mean,
you guys are constantly on the radio constantly sitting down and doing TV
interviews constantly.
There's articles in rolling stone and in fucking all these different magazines
and the scheduling today was kind of a cluster fuck to be honest.
And now,
and this is just like Monday.
I know.
No,
like he'll fight coming up Holly Holmes.
Not until now.
It's the November card and November card.
And that's going to be the biggest audience ever for a UFC.
The biggest,
yes it is.
GSP is going to be bigger than that.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
This will be bigger because this would be overseeing,
this one's going to be me.
It's going to be over 60,000 it'd be bigger than the Rogers arena.
It's going to be nuts.
So that hasn't ramped up yet.
No,
not really.
So now you're,
but even regular days,
like how the fuck do you relax?
She doesn't,
she trained me and everyday I have a problem.
He actually forced me to relax after this last camp cause usually I'm like back
in the gym like two days after because I just didn't know what to do with
myself.
And um,
he like forced me to have 20 days off of this time,
20 whole day.
And then she was like,
why do I need that number?
I like,
I can't get an answer right now,
but make it 20 was the problem here.
What's fascinating is you listened to him.
That's,
that's,
that's what you're saying that you're saying that
belief.
You know,
I've trained Vic Darchinyan amazing world champion right from Australia.
He's so stuck that around this fighting there right now.
And you know the personality,
everything.
She's born a fighter that we know.
But what she has is that belief that trust into a trainer.
When I show you something she believes in and she does it.
That belief I think comes with respecting.
We are working would the love,
the passion,
everything combined.
But her belief is even if you show it wrong to her,
she will make it right.
She will make it happen.
You know this the first time,
this last fight,
I put a chest protector on in the locker room.
I said,
champ,
you know why I'm wearing the chest protector.
I want you to hit that body when you angle off.
And she did it.
You know,
she does it.
She believes it.
She doesn't question.
She doesn't doubt.
Well,
you guys have a very unique relationship.
And one of the things I loves Edmon and every time he sends me a text message,
he doesn't call you Rhonda.
He calls you champ.
He reminded,
you know Shannon Briggs is Shannon the Canon Briggs.
He's crazy here.
Yeah,
let's go check out everything he does.
Like every Instagram videos.
Let's go champ.
It's all
he says,
let's go champ.
What are you doing champ?
You can't be drinking them sodas,
champ.
You need the cross.
Everybody chat it.
It's hilarious.
But he's,
he's really fun.
But he called.
It just reminds me that,
cause he only calls you champ.
That's what he calls you.
That's it around title.
I like,
fuck yeah.
Someone calling someone and tiger or bud or you know,
whatever.
Yeah.
Kayla Champs.
Sometimes champion Ana's champion.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's easy to trust him because like he's told you a couple of times before like
the fight,
like,
oh,
like remember when Mcmahon,
he said it was going to be a liver shot.
Yeah.
And I'm with Davis.
He's like,
it's going to be overhand.
Right.
And this last,
um,
look additionally the trip.
Yeah.
And then like with,
with uh,
Zingano,
he's like,
she's going to come out with something flying right away and you're going to
like,
check your check left and you're going to like,
you know,
it's going to be quick.
And then with this fight he said w with bat,
she was like,
she's going to sleep on her face.
He is swear to God.
He said,
you're going to knock her on.
She's asleep on her face.
And I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
All right.
I read about Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
It wasn't just that a you out,
but how like it was honor.
How are you doing some Armenians?
What are you doing?
Oh,
you know,
you know what it is?
Trust them though,
because every time it's getting crazy.
It's because of the preparation.
Would you see during training camp and what kind of sparring partners you hire?
I don't do sparrings in my gym for Rhonda.
Rhonda doesn't have that striking experience,
meaning competition experience.
So how can I get that?
I thought of,
I should get that in the gym.
She has competition experience in judo.
She is,
you know,
your competition.
We can't talk about that high,
how high level it is.
But boxing you don't,
she doesn't have any amateur boxing fights or amateur kickboxing fights,
anything like that.
So to get it,
I would get great sparring partners for her in the gym and in the gym.
When I get the great sparring partners,
I see Rhonda knocking out people from the liver shot maybe 2030 people for
training camp.
Those grills are hired.
Sparring partners,
they get paid.
So you know,
what were some of them are here.
Sparring partners in the gym where I,
you know,
helped them and I trained them and I,
she knows never charged them.
I work with them,
you know,
so I could build them,
give them what they need to be a champion and she drops all of those people in
the gym.
Of course she's going to do it during the fight.
Well,
how could she not a champion Laker,
how could she not?
She gets in there and she does it.
That's why you have as much of a belief in her as she has in your,
in your training of her.
You guys had,
that's why I say you have a very unique relationship,
which is why she wanted you right there.
When you sat down,
you were over there.
Get over here getting the touch.
You can never reach it.
We would eat dinner at night when she started her career and you feel like
training that we'll talk about boxing.
You know about what?
What?
What are we doing guider about it.
You know about the sweet science teacher and she would,
let's go to the gym and start working woodwork until 1:00 AM
on the mic.
Please take these pictures of like,
yeah,
me,
you and Ronnie were all at the gym at like one o'clock in the morning cause we
all went to dinner and we were so like amped up talking about fighting or like,
fuck yeah,
let's go right now.
Let's go right to lose her.
So like into fighting and you know,
you shouldn't see him go off on a tangent.
You'd be like,
makes me want to fight,
you know,
so me and menu or like let's go back,
go,
let me read week when turned around and went straight back to the gym.
Makes me want to fight with you can do that.
You just want to do it,
just go do it.
Why not?
Right.
Personality,
personality,
you know,
it has to work in with the trainer.
You know,
it's not only that I'm the best,
it works for her personality and you know,
does a video,
you guys that I put up on my Instagram page,
the,
I retweeted a pull that shit up his uh,
I think,
uh,
from,
I think I retweeted it from Dana or the UFC,
but you guys track training in Brazil on the beach,
those one of those workout days.
Oh though and go and uh,
you fucking hit and meds and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck is going on in your gym because you're,
your striking has accelerated in these giant jumps like every three or four
months.
When I watch like you hit and meds,
I'm like,
what the fuck are they doing?
It's like,
no,
you don't see that kind of results from other fighters,
these,
these giant leaps from the WWE.
If you go back to like I saw you guys hitting mitts before the Liz,
Liz Carmouche fight and you go back to before the batch call,
hey,
a fight like fucking [inaudible] is so different.
It's,
it's,
it's shocking.
You're only talking about a few years,
but there's difference between like someone who's like,
you know,
got a decent understanding of how to throw punches to someone who looks like a
fucking world champion.
Kickboxer or this is boxing
world champion.
Any giving any given day.
I always say that right now,
you know,
there is a few females out there,
no disrespect that are in the Olympic Games.
That one Olympic gold medal.
I even told Rhonda about a girl Reza,
you know,
there's uh,
yeah,
she,
she could buck,
she won the Olympic boxing gold metal.
Like a lot of respect to her.
She could definitely box.
You could punch amazing champion and Olympic gold medals,
but a professional boxing her weight class one 35 pounder.
She would destroy them.
Here it is right here on the big screen.
Okay.
This is a,
see what you guys are,
are hitting mets.
Oh,
those pants or in my car.
Ah,
I just thought it was,
yeah,
it's fucking speed is retarded.
Well,
the thing is people forget that.
Like when I won the title the first time it was my,
it was like my fifth profile look good after class just to get started.
Yeah,
just not like hit and spend so much different,
you know?
Well you have a lot of striking knowledge is very obvious.
I've seen the work you've done with Ellenberger and with Travis and the
Ellenberger.
There was a big difference between the way he was throwing punches and the way
he was moving after he started working with you.
And I could tell the way you,
you coacher and the way you coach fighters,
you,
you know a lot of shit about boxing.
There's a lot going on there with movement,
but it's also,
you're a very unusual athlete.
Rhonda,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sure you know this,
but there's a fucking fire burning inside you that is just so much hotter than
most people.
The intensity that you're bringing to it,
is that come from the way your mom raised you?
Is that something that's always been in you like
I think it's a mix between how I was raised and never wanting the Olympics.
Yeah.
That's like the best thing has ever happened to me because it's like now it's
just unlimited motivation forever because it's never going to be satiated.
Yeah.
I grew up as a little kid,
like,
you know,
I even before I did judo,
my dad convinced me music,
you're going to win the Olympics in swimming,
you're going to be didn't champion.
And then it switched in judo.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to be Olympic champion and this is my whole life.
That was like my obsession,
you know?
And I went when I was 17 and um,
it didn't go my way.
And then when I was 21 like I was so unhappy doing judo that I felt like that
was like my last shot.
Why were you so unhappy doing judo?
Because just it got to a point where it's very old school kind of training or
it's drilled into your head that you have to make yourself absolutely miserable
in order to deserve to win.
And so I was just like,
I was miserable all the time.
Why do you have to make yourself miserable?
What do you mean?
Like constantly overtrained always overtrained like I couldn't like my knee,
I have recovered so much since coming to MMA.
Like I was about to retire just because my knee was so bad in judo because like
I could barely walk some days they would,
I would wake up in the morning and it would take me like 20 minutes to maneuver
my knee enough so I could bend it again cause it would lock in place in the
middle of the night.
And you know like just the people that I was around,
like there was some of them that were cool but mostly I had no control over who
I lived with or who I was around all day long.
And so if you're around people that you don't really like constantly,
you know,
it just kind of like,
you're always watching what you say and always looking over your shoulder.
You can have a really relaxed and I didn't like where I lived and it was just
the actual process of training.
Like the training itself wasn't fun at all and it wasn't meant to be fun at all.
And like from when I was a kid from I think from,
I dunno,
2003 to 2006 nine 2000 to 2006 I cried every single practice and would lock
myself in the locker room and cry for another half hour afterwards.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it was only like when I got older that was able to shake myself and not
crying during training because if it didn't go exactly my way,
like if I had,
if I got thrown once,
you know,
by someone who was 50 pounds heavier and meet with five years more experience,
I would still cry about it.
And like I wouldn't then I'd be embarrassed that I was crying and I would cry
because I was embarrassed because I couldn't stop myself crying and line.
It would just keep going and you know?
Yeah.
So that's the how like Manny and all them knew me when I was a kid is I was
like,
my mom would bring me in there just to get beat up because they were really
tough guys,
you know?
And she would bring me to like four or five different gyms a week to get all the
different styles and they would beat up on me and I would get thrown once first
time I get thrown immediately start crying and I'm getting embarrassed,
crying more and then like,
but they were used to me crying,
you know,
and like I'd be able to finish the whole night and sometimes,
I'd be able to stop crying when they did the night.
And that was like comfortable with me in a way because I didn't have to be
embarrassed because they were used to me crying all the time.
And so they accepted me like that and they didn't think I was a stupid little
girl because I was crying during training and it,
and then it really sucked,
like moving to a different environment.
And then I don't know,
all these people don't know that I cry.
They don't know that it's my thing and now I'm like,
I have to start all over again.
And then it makes you cry even easier.
And Yeah,
let me fight with him before I start crying.
It wasn't until I ran away from home and was out on my own that I was able to
like stop myself from crying every night.
Then it would be like a couple times a week and then I kinda like got rid of it
mostly.
But like since doing MMA,
I haven't cried during training.
When did you run away from home?
Like a week after I turned 18.
Wow.
That's not running away from home.
That's like moving out.
Well,
you know,
13 I know,
but no one knew I was leaving
and it was in the middle of the night.
He just couldn't take it anymore.
Um,
you know,
um,
I was at a point where I felt like every second of my day was somebody else's
decision,
you know,
so like I,
I mean,
I am so grateful to my mother.
She's an amazing person.
She had the perfect job raising me and I was kind of a stupid and short sighted
kid.
I didn't realize how much she was doing for me at the time.
And I was,
you know,
had like Rapunzel and the castle syndrome.
I thought like,
oh,
woe is me.
I'm locked in the castle and my mom was so mean and now I'm like,
oh my God,
she's a genius.
But you know,
at the time,
yeah it was,
I was recognized as having a lot of potential,
very,
very young and was treated like,
like that,
you know,
the like I was like the prodigy kid very young and got really intense,
really structured training very early on.
And like it just became a whole life.
Like I didn't have,
I never went to a single like dance or partying school.
I never went on a single date.
Like I trained all the time and then dropped out of school sophomore year so I
could train all the time.
And that was like my life.
And then I felt like my life was like out of my control.
And so I,
I left and was like,
well,
I'm going to win and I'm going to do this stuff on my own and I'm going to show
everybody that actually know what I'm talking about.
And because I felt like my opinion and no one had any respect for what I thought
and I was always doing what everybody else said I should be doing.
And so I went off and I bounced around a bunch of different clubs is a very
crazy time,
was moving cities like every couple a couple of months.
And then after on 2006 I was like the first American woman in nine years to win
a World Cup in judo with no coach.
I did it with no coach.
And then I also,
I won in Sweden and I meddled in Finland when you know the Americans are getting
their asses kicked,
they weren't meddling,
they weren't getting past the first round.
And so like I was kind of my way to get respect from everybody else was,
and then I ended up moving to Canada because I was like,
fuck all of us coaches,
I'm going to do this something on.
And I was just,
I was,
I had to like the national training center there where they couldn't coach me,
but I was beating the girls.
So they were like,
yeah,
we'll come here and we'll,
they'll get used to you and whatever.
So I was just kind of like a body for them and I was like pretty much on my own
training,
on my own with no direction and no coaching.
And I was like,
couldn't coach you because you're a nice state citizen.
So the idea was,
yeah,
yeah.
And um,
I was just like so stubborn and not getting enough respect that I felt like I
was going to go win with nobody's help.
And then I ended up getting asked back to one of the gyms I was kicked out of
when I was a kid.
Why were you kicked out?
I was kicked out.
I was kicked out several times.
Um,
I was kicked out like once because like,
I dunno,
my old coaches wife,
like didn't like my mom.
I don't know.
They were having like argument and I'm like,
then like the last time I got kicked out was,
um,
I was at the German super and I lost.
I,
um,
I remember first round I was fighting to go from Finland and I was ahead by
looking Yoko,
which is like a decent score and there's like 40 seconds left and I threw her
with an Occi Gari,
which you don't know where that is,
but I pretty much fall into the guard and my arm is out.
And then I just ended up in the arm Barbara Way I got onboard and,
but my elbow like just located right away.
So this 18 year old little me,
um,
my brain is going and I'm like,
well,
I was about to turn 18.
I was almost there.
I'm like,
well my elbow is already out,
you know,
so I might as well just try to get out.
Right.
And so I tried to get out in my elbow,
goes back in,
and then she pops out again.
And then I think I'm like,
well,
she'd already popped it out twice,
you know,
so I might as well,
like I can't just like let her do it twice.
And then I ended up getting out and run the clock out.
I won the match.
But then immediately right after I fought,
like,
you know,
this chick,
um,
uh,
what was it Lucy to cost,
who is a world Olympic champion from France?
And I couldn't even lift my arm from my side.
Like I had to pick my hand up to like pull up to my side but like to fight.
And then,
um,
then I lost her and then I fought this German girl next and I still like
couldn't even lift my hand up and I would like to bring my hand up and ended up
winning that fight against a German girl.
And then I ended up fighting a earth's quizzle near who was a world and Olympic
bronze medalist.
And,
um,
it was a closer fight,
but I lost.
And so I was all bummed out and I was talking to my,
like first boyfriend at the time,
which was like,
um,
you know,
I never had a date and never had a part,
nothing in,
in high school.
Right.
And so like,
I'm a 17 year old girl,
about to be 18.
And,
um,
this guy in his twenties,
it's like on the national team,
like has a thing for me,
you know what I mean?
Like I thought like,
I was so cool because like I was talking to this guy and of course,
you know,
my mom and my coaches are totally against it and they're like,
you're not allowed to talk to him and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
You know,
of course I would talk to him anyway.
And um,
so we were seeing each other for a while.
I ended up seeing this guy for like two years actually.
Um,
but I went back to the hotel and it was like,
screw this,
I hate judo.
And then,
um,
so I went back and I was hanging out with him and then my coach went down to the
lobby,
got the key from my room and came up and walked in the room with me and this guy
freaked out.
Losses minds is,
you're out,
you're gone.
I'm done with you.
You're out of the gym,
you're out of everything.
I'll never want to see your face again.
All that stuff.
Just because you're having fun with a guy.
Yeah,
I don't get it.
Why was he so mad?
Because I was told not to and I disobeyed the,
they could tell you who to hang out with.
Yeah.
I could tell you who you could date.
I told you I had no control over my life.
It was ridiculous.
What kind of crazy that just old school judo mentality.
I guess so.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Plus,
you know,
I was,
he was,
as you know,
it's sleazy.
Kind of preying on the young girl that I didn't see that I thought we were in
love and all this stuff.
So your coach might have been kind of protecting you and everybody was,
you know,
in hindsight I'm like,
oh my God,
how much older there was this car than you like five and a half years.
And you were like 18 or not quite what we were talking since I was like about to
turn 16 so it's illegal.
Yeah.
It was illegal.
How dare he.
Oh,
okay.
Well that's different.
That kind of makes sense I guess.
But still like you,
you were 18 at the time when he was about to turn 18,
it was still illegal.
And then I went home and my mom's like,
you know,
you're not going to do judo for a year and you better forget the name of
whatever his name was and you're going to work and you're going to support
yourself and you're going to pay me this amount of money to live in my house.
And I'm thinking,
I'm like,
well,
I want to do judo and if I want to work I'm going to go pay for my rent wherever
I want.
You know,
this is what I'm thinking.
And so that night I um,
I got social,
I used to get social security checks because of,
uh,
my dad,
he died.
And so I,
I went opened a bank account and I rerouted social security checks to go into my
account.
And then like I had to get dentist stuff done.
So I scheduled like dentists things.
So I'd still be under my mom's insurance.
And then I've got myself a plane ticket.
Was the social security money to be right after my last dentist appointment.
Whoa.
That's intense.
And then like in the middle of the night,
like I secretly pack my bags and all this stuff and I waited until like two
o'clock in the morning or whatever to like walk several blocks away from the
house and then call the taxi several blocks away from the house and then took a
taxi to the airport.
Wow.
How long did it take for your mom knew what was going on and the next morning
did you call her?
Did you tell her where you were now?
When did you let her know?
She says I left it.
No,
I don't remember if I did to be honest.
But I went to like my best friend and Lily's house all the way across the,
the country in New York.
Cause I was like,
I want to work at Stewart's,
which is like their convenient store.
I was like,
I'm gonna get a job at a convenience store and I'm going to trade on my own and
I'm going to do it on my own and I'm going to show everybody that I could do it
on my own,
you know?
Uh,
no,
I was just,
I was a young,
dumb kid and just,
I had no like way to rebel,
so I was like little miss perfect.
And that was like my little,
I suddenly just blew up one day and like took off.
How long was it before you talked to your mom again?
Like two years.
You didn't talk to her at all for two years.
Like anytime we tried to talk it would turn into a huge blow up.
So like,
yeah,
in like my whole family too.
Like I,
you know,
I,
it was terrible thing that I did.
I like took off and I like really hurt my mom and my sisters really resented me
for it.
And a,
there were plenty of thanksgivings where like I would sit there and no one would
talk to me since like,
yeah,
after that and kind of fucking intense family,
really intense download.
It took many years for them to actually like forgive me for what I did.
Wow.
Yeah.
That is crazy.
The world of judo is a lot like the world of wrestling with that overtraining,
isn't it?
Yeah.
What,
why is that like so caught?
Why?
How come no one's car?
Have they caught up to that sense of if people figured that out soon?
It's such an old sport where it's like Bushido martial arts and they're like
thinking like,
oh,
the way since icon on my name was still this thing.
I don't know if it was like,
I don't know,
what was it called?
Something training that this wouldn't kind of training in Japan or the like in
the winter where they'd opened all the windows and to be frost on the mats and
they would purposely make you freezing cold while you train,
which is terrible for you.
But it'd be like,
you know,
old school mentality,
mental toughness,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
And they would always do like more is more for them or is more and more is more
and yeah,
I was so constantly overtrained all the time and constantly cutting weight and
like not having any way to actually make weight healthily.
No tools,
no education,
anything.
Just getting weighed every week and being yelled at for being too heavy.
Like theirs is so poorly run.
You know it,
you got yelled at for being too heavy.
Yeah,
I get weighed.
I used to get weighed every Tuesday and then I would,
I would not drink any water after Monday packed is,
and I wouldn't eat dinner and to try and be lighter and I would still be like
too heavy and then,
you know,
then I would eat,
all this kind of fuck with you and give you like body image issues when you're
young and someone's telling you your shoe heavy and the yelling at you about
that different long time.
Yeah.
16 year old girl and being told that you're,
you're like you're too fat or you're too,
but you know what should you be eating that all the time?
Constantly.
I thought if,
unless I wait exactly 63 kilograms.
I was ugly for the longest time.
Yeah,
it took a while to get over.
That's why like I'm so big and be like doing like Bonnie and miss stuff and and
like the do nothing bitch like shirts.
They all went to Didi Hirsch,
which is um,
it's like free like mental,
like mental health clinic.
That's like a 52 different schools around La that helps girls with,
you know,
body image and eating disorders and suicidal,
like all these different things to give like those kids treatment because I
didn't have anyone to talk to you.
I didn't even really know that I had that much of a problem.
But
that old school mentality does produce mental toughness though.
It's like such a catch 22.
It's the dumbest way to train to overtrain people and to make them fight whether
dehydrated or it's,
the issue with wrestlers is the issue with judo.
People with a lot of like old school martial arts people,
but I'm torn on it because on the other hand,
like who the fuck is tougher than wrestlers?
Like getting through that they developed this indomitable determination,
you know,
because they've gone,
they're so used to being uncomfortable.
They're so used to pushing when they're exhausted,
pushing when they're dehydrated,
pushing when they're not at their optimum.
I think there's a
four.
I think when you're in a developmental phase,
it's a good thing to be due to be overtraining a little bit and we made
uncomfortable and you know,
to have to run laps when your foot,
great personalities.
When you're a professional level and this is the time you need to perform.
Whatever personality you've developed is already developed by now.
Then as time to train professionally,
like we've had situations and sparring sessions,
like if one of my good guys or anybody gets cut with a punch,
you know,
they take a knee,
I didn't relax.
You know,
there's always another day.
You don't need that extra punishment to the head.
It's not healthy for you.
But some people don't understand that they pushed their fighters,
they get dropped and it's happened to,
you know,
even with champ or opponent get dropped and they keep on pushing and pushing.
Oh,
she's okay.
Go One more.
Boom,
dropped again.
Go One more.
That's not healthy.
You know,
you have to know where to push out a push,
but she's absolutely right about young gates.
Sometimes you want to create that personality not giving up and the only way to
do it as you got to be a little bit old school and hard on them,
you know,
and she's had that,
but now it's,
she has that,
you do it more professional and more structured,
better.
You know?
Sparrings the right way.
Sparring partners,
everything is done for her and she loves it.
That's why she loves it.
That's what she said.
She didn't like that and now she loves it.
Yeah.
That grind,
the determination that you developed from that grind is rec irreplaceable?
Yeah.
But once you have it for you,
is it a matter of just like keeping the sword sharp like,
well,
what do,
what keeps you or your motivation high
at this point?
Oh,
oh,
just seems like unfinished,
unfinished your life.
Your career.
Career is more left to do.
I don't feel like I'm done yet.
And because of what the Olympics is,
just like you wouldn't Olympic gold metal and you're done right with you have
seen,
what am I really done
when you say you're done,
you might be done right now.
He might walk out of here and go,
fuck this sport,
but I'm not going to go do movies.
Fuck up on the big scale.
I mean you could really do whatever you want at this point,
right?
You're rich,
you're famous.
You can do whatever you want.
You transcend to the sport or ready,
you know you can do whatever you want.
It feels unfinished though.
What would make it feel finished?
Cyborg.
That definitely would,
that's like she's your,
your Ivan Drago right.
She never stops off.
You know,
like I'll,
I'll,
I'll know,
you know,
I'll probably go a little longer waiting for her,
but you know,
if she showed up sooner rather than later,
you know,
I don't know how much longer I would go after that.
Well she seems to want you to fight her to have your weight,
which is very fascinating to me because,
um,
you know,
she knows that you're the 135 pound champ and she wants,
and she knows you fought at one 45 before,
so she wants you to fight where she is.
But she's clearly,
the thing is
someone who uses stairways and I was kind of things they need that to mentally
think that they have an advantage that they didn't earn bigger.
It's a crutch for her.
She needs to feel
like she's somehow has an advantage from the outside because she doesn't think
she's good enough with just what she has.
That's why.
That's why you dope in the first place.
Cause you feel like the best you have isn't good enough.
She feels like if we fight fair,
the best she has isn't going to be good enough.
That's why she wants it to be somehow stacked in our favor.
Well,
the steroid that she got caught with his story that allows you to keep size,
he keep your muscle while you're cutting weight.
It's a one of the best ones for that allows.
So she's obviously not just concerned with making the weight,
but concerned with making the weight and being big,
you know?
Yeah.
That's the thing.
Like if you could make weight and be on steroids,
even if it's,
uh,
making weight a relatively making weight friendly steroid,
you're still like without a,
you're capable of moving down and you see what happens to people when they
stopped,
when they get off the steroids,
you see what they look like.
It's very easy for them to drop down.
They immediately,
they immediately shrink up.
Yeah.
It changes everything.
It changes everything and it's all like an insecurity thing.
That's all it is.
It's a fascinating time when you see these guys that were on TRT or the people
that were involved in the urine testing,
which was like they would say,
is basically an intelligence test.
If you test after your fight and you're on steroids,
you're a fucking idiot.
It's that simple.
But you could cycle all the way up until right before your fight.
If you use and the right stuff,
cycle off of it.
Weigh in,
fight,
do,
get your drug test and still test clean and so you're not really clean.
You,
you were never cleaned.
You would just clean enough to pass that task,
but your body's still had all the effects of those steroids.
You can't do that anymore.
This is Jeff Novitsky guy is not fucking playing games and the testing that
they're implementing on these athletes is no joke.
I mean,
they're,
they're going to show up at your fucking house.
The same that I did growing up,
I was under Messiah testing for now it's 14 years old.
And then when I started
doing MMA,
I was like,
really?
They just hand me a cup and say,
go in this other room and come back with something.
I was a 14 year old girl.
They're like,
drop your pants,
pull up your shirt,
spin around in a circle.
Okay.
Make sure I can see it while you're pitting pitting and they're like,
you know,
it was like the most thorough and I remember the first time I was okay,
I drink eight bottles of water and be able to do it,
but I was so nervous,
you know and and I'm like,
wait a minute to fight for Strikeforce title or UFC title is less strict and you
know,
less thorough testing.
Then a 14 year old at the junior Miami youth in judo.
Think about that.
Crazy 14 year old at the junior Miami youth international and yeah,
judo in Florida.
Well up until a few restrict your testing.
Then the first couple of times I won the UFC title
now,
now it's the same testing.
When they brought with Sada in to do the testing,
I was like thank God.
And you know what's funny at the same chick that like was my auto competition
testing lady from when I was a kid.
She was like my same lady again.
She like showed up to the gym.
I was like,
oh my God,
that's hilarious.
Because I was an out of competition testing too.
Like did it for so long and we're like having to fill out those forms all the
time was such a pain in the ass and now it's like,
it's really,
really,
really easy.
Like I'm out of competition testing was,
I hated it because of the paperwork,
but I was always so happy that they did it,
you know?
And now I'm like really confident with what the testing is for us now.
It's pretty intense and it will absolutely weed out all the cheaters.
It's just going to take time.
But for these guys that relied on it for the longest time,
you're seeing a difference in the way they look.
Yeah.
You know,
their,
their bodies are changing radically.
And I mean look at the difference in v Tor before and after the Weidman fights.
The thing like when you look at these people from before,
when they're using an after,
when they're not,
they look entirely different and cyber looks and ways exactly the same.
If she gets off,
it will be very easy for her to make white from what we've seen from every
single other person has.
Got It.
So you think she's still on it right now?
I think that it's possible.
It's very possible.
I can't like say the proof anything,
a lot of da.
But if you look the exact same as you did when you were using and what changed?
Did you ever see the video of her when she had her first fight?
Oh,
when she's like tiny,
completely different word.
Plenty different body.
Yeah.
I miss a woman's body.
I mean we were like,
you know,
it was,
it very different.
I mean she's so thick now.
She's so thick and muscular and yeah,
I mean you get thick and muscular from hard work,
but boy she's,
the change is so radical.
It's such a giant difference.
So to see a,
I mean men can put that kind of size on through power lifting and hard way,
but see a woman put that kind of size on I kind of thickness this is the size.
I mean like the shape of your head
and shoulders to the width of her shoulders,
like the whole deal.
Like when you add testosterone to a woman's body,
so many things change.
It's not,
I mean it's,
it's even more radical adding it to a man's body.
I mean,
when the guys were on the juice,
you know,
they get bigger and thicker and everything like that,
but they're just bigger and thicker men.
When a woman goes on the juice,
it's,
you're taking a woman who you,
you know,
your body only has a certain amount of testosterone that's being produced.
That's it.
It's a very small amount and then when you add all this extra tests to it,
me see what happens with transgender women when women turn into
very,
it's very similar to the hormone therapy that
well,
woman to man transgender goes through.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
One thing I'm like,
yeah,
and they'd be,
man,
man.
Yeah.
You literally do turn into a man.
Everything changes.
Your bone structure changes,
you get thicker.
You're,
you mean the shoulders,
the face,
everything.
It all,
it's like changes your ability to take punishment as well.
That's what's really weird.
Like the different stream guys who are on it and off of it,
their ability to take a shot.
Like you see the difference in their ability to absorb punches or they get off
of it and one punch and did their legs go.
It's,
it's crazy.
It's the confidence too.
It really is.
If you walk in there with confidence,
like there's no way this person's going to touch me and the hit you,
you don't care if you walk in there without those,
those,
it's what it is.
Like doping is,
is a mental handicap.
Mm.
And when they use,
it's the mental crutch.
Like when you take that off,
it's not just what they physically lose,
it's what they mentally lose.
And that's the hardest thing for them to let go.
You'll use once and you're going to have that forever.
You're going to have that mental handicap forever and there's no way you can get
it.
You can fix it.
Right.
You'll always know that you used and you always know that it helped you and
your,
and you'll always feel like less without it.
Yeah.
Because when you have it like the,
the guys that are juiced up,
they feel like they're fucking superman.
You know,
like when you go back to the early days of the UFC,
when you could just do whatever the fuck you wanted.
I go back to the pride days.
Those are my favorite days.
Fucking like,
I dunno what an Vander lay was doing,
but I'm assuming everything,
you know,
I don't know.
But I mean he was like one of my all time favorite fighters to watch cause it
wasn't even like watching a human,
it was like watching some rabid hyena that took a human form and learned Moitai
Ron across the cage,
the fucking shit out of you and stop your head when you were down.
It was wild,
crazy shit to watch.
But it was just,
it was a human,
it was just so far gone off the hormone hormone spectrum.
And that's the thing I like.
You get into a setting where everyone's doing it,
then you're hitting and punching harder than a person should write and you're
taking more damage and more punishment than a person's shoe.
And that is how someone is going to eventually die.
Hmm.
Well one of the big concerns with me is the lack of,
um,
the,
when they're trying to take out the ivs and I understand why they're doing it
because a,
they're trying to stop people from masking doping.
Like Novitsky came on my podcast and explained it to me that there has been
instances where people used bags.
Yeah.
Flushes your system out and somehow or another can mask and also blood doping
and blood doping is totally legit.
They've used it in cycling for years where you take your blood out,
you know,
your body replenishes the blood and you put that blog back in right before you
fight.
I know that people have done that before.
Was shocking to me.
Is that the you a UFC in Nevada state athletic commission just like just a few
years ago.
It wasn't even testing for EPO.
It wasn't that long ago.
It was like less than a decade.
Like EPO wasn't something that they tested for,
which is crazy cause it's,
I mean if anything relies on endurance is a critical factor and endurance.
It's finding,
it's one of the,
the most critical factors.
Cause if,
if you're running in a race and you're slower because you're tired,
you don't get kicked in the face,
you know,
the differences.
So giant in the fact that they didn't take that into consideration when all
those years,
all those years they had been testing cyclist for it and even testing them,
they were still doing it.
They're still pulling it off.
There's still cheating and uh,
the fact that they'll,
they can test plastics in the blood from the ivy bag.
That it's fascinating to me.
That's amazing.
I mean I'm,
I'm completely supportive.
Ib like Bam,
even even just for weight cutting.
Did you ever use them for weight cutting?
Once in 2005 right before the world championships in Egypt and Cairo.
And it was the worst ever because in judo you have like an hour and a half
sometimes from when to when you're going to go on,
then you're in a fight like seven times,
you know,
it's crazy.
And so I got the opportunity is Geez,
it because a friend of mine had it and it wasn't,
you know,
it was still legal,
uh,
back then it wasn't,
you know,
it wasn't a thing.
So I wasn't like I was cheating.
It's just in,
you know,
other people.
I just didn't have the means to do it and other people did.
And so I got the opportunity to use it and I was like,
all right,
I'll try it out.
I had a really,
really bad way cut.
I was,
you know,
kind of like being a dumb kid and I was,
this is after I ran away from home and I had a terrible cut.
It was like 2005.
It was like,
yeah,
that same year.
And um,
I ended up getting chills,
like my whole body got chills.
Like my whole body was swollen.
I've never felt that slow in that terrible.
Like it was the worst thing.
I would have been the ivy from the IV.
Yeah,
I was at a Dema.
Did you have a Dema?
Was that a yes?
Listening to an issue that,
uh,
people get when they have id Ivs for some reason your body does.
It just reacts in some sort of a strange way with the water.
Uh,
no,
but I always remember I got chills.
Like I couldn't stop myself from shivering and like I was really,
really slow and sluggish and I absolutely hated it.
I hated it and never did it again.
When she told me she doesn't do it for Mna,
when she started her career,
I said,
I love it.
It's so great.
That was none of my boxers do it.
Yeah.
And if,
if,
if you need medical attention from cutting weight shoes,
you're in the wrong division.
There's a lot of people on the wrong vision.
You can't,
you just drink normally.
You're not sick where you can,
you know,
raise
your hand and drink.
Normal issue is rehydrating the brain.
That's one of the big ones.
Rehydrating the brain takes a long time all day.
I was like,
what?
I got 24 hours,
24 hours and I don't have been out because then you don't have to have an hour
and a half to three hours and out the wind like four times a month or something
like that.
I mean that's really like,
I couldn't do that fighting Lind 35 now the difference though is that that
involves grappling only and even though there are some head impacts me,
it's not the same.
Joe,
we do training camp before sharp at Lake,
let's say,
depending on the fight were sharp ed 147 pounds,
148 pounds,
right?
She's sharp,
she's explosive.
One 49 let's say you drink gradually and you make that weight during the fight.
Even heavyweights in boxing,
look at their weight.
It's not in every way.
You could go up as much as you want and you have to know where you're strong.
Get right during training,
right,
so you just drink.
You'd become one 48 four nine you're good to go.
You fight.
What's the problem?
Why would you do ivy to get boom right away or bloated?
That's why most of these guys in MMA can't move.
Sometimes they're not as sharp,
they're young and when they move and I look at them,
I'm like,
why are they so slow?
Sometimes you,
you know,
compare it to boxing and you see those guys,
old school fighters,
they're in their forties there were quick and explosive.
None of them do ivy.
They don't do ivy boxers don't use ivs.
I don't use it.
But what about radical weight cuts stuff?
You make it like a guy like Julio,
Cesar Chavez Jr.
He cuts a lot of wind,
a lot of weight.
Probably.
He uses it.
That's why he's so slow.
What happened to him?
You see him as being the greatest.
He's a young guy.
You sometimes you face,
he's like,
cause I'm being,
I think he's getting too much buzzy.
Good luck.
Discipline.
Discipline does.
Yeah,
there's definitely a lack of that,
but I think that's what it ends of that.
But God,
you start handling it,
the sharp,
I don't think you need that.
You don't need that.
I don't believe in it.
I mean,
I think you're correct,
but I think there are a lot of issues where there's just not enough weight
classes.
I think,
um,
there's a lot of issues where guys are tweeners,
you know,
they're not,
if they're not quite gap you're talking about is too much in boxing we have two
pounds to 10 pounds is so bad,
but there's,
there's like 85 to two oh five is crazy.
That's a giant jump.
Two,
two,
two oh five to two 65 is fucking nuts.
I mean that's a nutty one.
Yeah.
I think there should be a to 25 for sure.
What you're saying is they,
it's too much of a difference when they go down so low then they want to gain
it.
The only way is to stick an IV in there so you can know,
um,
gained that weight quicker.
But I think 24 hours is enough for you.
Like if you could raise your hand and drink water.
I think ivs for people that when they're sick and you know,
they're throwing up and they can't like move,
they're exhausted.
You,
you know,
you're right on there.
And so they could recover.
That's the purpose of life,
me,
right?
It is.
I don't believe it helps it all.
I think it's a hindrance.
But if you're having a terrible weight cut and you're really worried about this
fight,
it's really,
it helps put your mind at ease.
If you think,
oh no,
no,
it's fine.
I'll have an IV and like the magical tier and it's like this bad way cut.
Never happen.
Well they,
they do think that is the better way to replenish the fluid in the brain.
It's still takes 70 something hours to fully replenished guys that the guys that
use it.
What I notice is when they're warming up in the locker room,
like I see them during training,
right?
So I know how there's people that sweat more than the others.
So you know the athlete,
but the guys that use it right in the locker room,
when they're starting their warm up there sweating,
you see that the body's not crisp and sharp.
You know,
it's something that the normal,
yeah,
it's something that I don't see usually during training because if you're
drinking your water,
you're coming to training,
you're normal,
you're fit,
you're healthy.
Let's add one 50 or whatever it is,
right?
I know that athlete and we're on the pads,
you sharp,
you know,
wrestling this and that.
He's looking good,
sweating normally.
And then you see during the fight they were,
this person hasn't even warmed up and soaking wet.
There's too much in your body because you're right,
your body can only absorb water back as fast as it does.
Why does it expel that much and only keep so much?
Because that's what's best for it.
It does it that way because it's best for it.
Not because you know,
it's suddenly just,
you know,
while it was evolving and I was like,
oh this is the best I could do,
or your body doesn't understand dehydrating.
And then 24 hours later going into a hand to hand combat situation.
Nobody understands that.
Like,
you know,
you're living in Africa,
there's not that much water.
And you know,
there could only be one day of rain and you know,
like all dry up the next day and you need to drink as much as possible and then
your shadow.
I got a water for a while.
You know,
these kind of situations happen for many,
many,
many years.
And why do we only,
we hydrate as fast as we do.
Nature never developed an ivy.
That's why I treated Campbell's.
Campbell's can rehydrate faster and us,
right.
They can hold a lot more water.
Yes.
All that stuff.
So it's just like,
it's physically possible for you to evolve that way.
So why did we evolve this way?
Well there are people though that are champions,
like Weidman cuts a lot of weight and I don't know how he's going to do with the
ivy ban because a,
he's a big boy,
you know?
Weidman's well over 200 pounds gets down to one 85 I think during the training.
If they do the training right and they see where he sharp out,
how they could deal with it.
You know,
if you're mentally tough,
you could gradually drifted.
It just drink throughout the day.
100% of you'll be okay.
I think.
I don't believe in it.
We're also going to get smaller.
They're going to have to get physically smaller.
They're going to have to not only about being how big,
you know,
you see these guys are,
you're not bloated,
but they can't move.
I don't want to be that way either.
Speed kills.
Remember,
we know that.
Everybody knows that that speeds.
Very,
very important.
The problem is with a lot of people there,
they're worried about being smothered by a bigger guy.
They're worried about being held and got to learn.
You learn not to get smothered.
They got to know how to fight.
You know?
They got to learn not to lie down on their back and let somebody be on top of
them.
Get out of that position filled the established way.
The things have been for a long time.
So now that this breakup and the established way,
exactly it's going to cost.
Just
like I stopped weightlifting a long time ago and then almost two years ago now
because weights no strength and conditioning for her bulky.
If you don't do any strength and conditioning are only two pound dumbbell
shadowboxing.
Do you worry at all about like injury prevention?
It's one of the benefits of strength and conditioning they think is injury
prevention.
They can,
you know,
strengthen up areas,
joints back if I,
if anything's wrong,
you know I can go see like a physical therapist and he could not give me stuff
to do or whatever.
But I mean I have such a base of doing straight conditioning for so many,
so many years.
That's like my [inaudible] is balanced the way it is.
You know,
there's not like an imbalance and I had to make up for it through strength and
conditioning and yeah,
I don't want to.
And now it's like I'm worried about being too bulked up where I can't fight the
way I want to find quicker hens or how explosive combination.
She's fluid.
She does a stretching.
She does two pound dumbbell workouts,
which in the 10th round she's averaging in the shadow boxing.
When she said her works again,
we know if we're on the shadow box,
she's not going to be fucking Gary.
I always say she's not gonna just do it so it can look pretty.
She's really shadowboxing.
She imagines there's an opponent in front of her and she has to kill them.
Throws 500 how many?
Five 75 575 punches in three minutes with a pound pound dumbbell.
That's ridiculous.
That's automatically strength and conditioning plus 10 plus 10 that you know
you're going to be fine.
Your hands in the 10th round,
10 rounds of the unit.
Their boxing.
I always say in their shadow boxing,
this is not sure of us and as you just loosening up up,
up,
right.
But she does it.
You're not throws the punches with the weights,
with intention,
with intention.
And then we go to Santa Monica stairs.
She gets her legs.
She does her core.
She,
there's 2000 sit ups every day.
Oh,
so you are doing conditioning is,
yeah,
but it's not like have years in patio,
like doing cleans or bench pressing or like do you ever see like Mayweather or
doing anything like that?
And did you ever see like any of those great I did was Muhammad Ali,
like hitting the iron or anything like that.
You know,
none of that word.
And there's a reason for that fight physical,
whatever is fighting we and then the time,
right?
How much you do and what you do and he doesn't know what you're doing.
It at devil's advocate though,
Hoffeld Dolson Jolson,
his last fight against Anthony Pettis was that he pushed them all in the most
ferocious paces I've ever seen for a five round fight.
And he went through an extensive strength and conditioning program with nick
curse on one of the guys who was a disciple of mob Marinovich and I had curse on
the podcast,
explained to me all the different stuff.
They had to do a lot of pliers,
a lot of explosive drills and different than lifting though.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We do conditioning,
but we don't do like lifting,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of people think that lifting in fact slows you down and provides you with
an unknown,
an unnatural workload on your muscles,
which fucks you up and training because you like your bench.
Like if you do bench press all the time,
like your chest is all fucked up and sore,
so that way when you're training,
you're going to like,
you're going to have this issue.
You're,
you're sore and you're all ripped up.
Your chest,
as you know,
is all filled with lactic acid
and you're right about,
doesn't use,
did an absolutely great job.
He was physically amazingly fit.
And I know the guy you're talking about,
he did a hell of a job,
but it's the training also,
Rafael Cordeiro done an amazing job,
hunters tactical approach to it and there is all of it combined,
but he knew that he needs to win that fight,
not only with the tactical aspect of it,
with the physical ability to conditioning.
So he did his job right.
When you have an athlete,
you need to know what you need to do to make that athlete.
Her guild was fastest and the strongest fighter.
Rhonda,
we're talking about Cyborg gear.
Rhonda with one hand,
we'll toss around Cyborg.
She will know where she is even at one 45 the problem is it has to be fair,
a fight,
and we do it pure.
She's never,
you know,
done anything unfair when it comes down to sports.
And she fought at one 45 like I said before,
is because she would walk around one 48 people wouldn't want to fight her.
So we said she could jump in and fight tomorrow for her to get experience
because she was always training,
but nobody would want to fight her.
So when they call you one day before for a fight,
would you be willing,
you're a fighter to fight at one 35 when you're walking around one 48
[inaudible] 45 of course one 45 why would you lose all that weight in one day?
Right?
And when you know you're a fire is a monster,
she'll beat anybody.
Of course.
Fight at one 45 so when you fight at one 35 how much weight are you cutting to
get down to their 15 pounds?
So he cut 15 pounds in.
How long?
Um,
I mean I get around 10 over like three days before 10 over.
So it sounds the last three days.
So it's,
is it a,
just watching your diet and coming back on your water?
Her pretty much the lightest that I could get with that.
You know,
that like I can't lose any more fat when I'm at like 43 and then like the last
like eight pounds has to be water cause that's just,
you know,
I just can't get any smaller than that.
That's when you get like super lean like right before the wagons.
And um,
if you,
if you ever consider,
I mean,
what do you think about the idea of fighters not cutting any weight at all?
I mean it seems to be almost a necessary evil at this stage of the game,
but I really wish it weren't and I really would like to see fighters just fight
at whatever is the healthiest weight for them.
I feel like I'm actually like,
and my best shape and the best fighter that I possibly can be.
If I make 35 and then go back up to like 47 48 the next day,
like why would that be better than if you fought at one 48 if you just felt like
you just didn't cut any weight at all?
So much more disciplined in order to to to do that,
to get to the 45 I could feel a whole lot more.
You know what I mean?
I can kind of blur the lines of my diet a level.
I won't have to be so disappointed.
Wouldn't have to beat so many ounces at this hour for weeks and weeks and weeks
ahead of time.
And so I feel like when I'm at the point where I'm about to actually go fight,
I don't feel the weight cut from the day before.
Like I,
it's this crazy feeling where I feel like I'm inhabiting this body that I only
have for like a day.
Like my,
my,
my fight night body.
It's like everything is peaked up to that day and it's what I'm finally like
inhabiting this body that can like,
like I feel like a fucking Ninja dude.
Me Right now is not right.
You know when you hit the gym right now start training [inaudible] I know we're
going to go back and show them how it is,
but you don't know like
yeah,
I can describe to you a Howard feels like after all that work and all of that
perfect food and perpetrating perfect peaking and it's all like done and it's
all like been fine tuned.
So I could be the best that it possibly like is physically possible for the
human form to be for this 24 hour period that I have.
Like I'm perfectly peaked.
It feels fucking amazing and I don't think I could get that feeling without
cutting the 35 first.
Wow.
That's fast.
And then when you're hungry,
you know your opponent,
you have to punish them for that.
You know,
you think about it like when you actually get to put on like a four ounce gloves
and he does like,
um,
his rap,
he does the best rap like ever.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
But like this is a fight that day wrap is like different than his training rap.
Like when I actually have that wrap on and those small gloves on,
like I feel like I could rob a fucking liquor store
and we don't need her liquor store.
Something better.
That's why you started about what will I will tell you.
I like when you guys first started working together.
I mean,
she was,
she was describing it like you,
you knew that she was a,
a judo player and she was getting into MMA.
Like what was like the first couple of training sessions when
she came in?
I didn't want to train her because I had my hands full and I had,
you know,
mm hmm Vantis Marty rose in WBC champion and Olympian and Vic and I was working
with all of them and I was like,
what is this girl doing?
You know,
what is she gonna do with this?
Right.
Is she serious?
Is She not?
And I don't like to jump into things.
I like to wait till it's the right time.
Timing.
I feel like for me as the most important thing that I've learned throughout my
career,
you know,
I opened up a gym when I was 16 years old and doing all of this,
I learned that patients sometimes on timing is very important because in my life
I went through a lot of hard days because I was a kid myself,
didn't understand what I'm getting into and I've been through a lot of tough
days.
So I like to stay patient and just watch and see,
figure out what the person wants to do with their life and then I could guide
them if I can,
I will.
If I can't,
I'll give him a pointer.
You know,
you could do it better with this person or you do it this way and some listen
and some don't.
We know that Ron is an amazing student.
I figured out right away because within the three,
four months she was in my gym,
I would tell her,
go ahead,
stay on the bag.
And she would go hit the bag and really hit the bag until I paid attention to
her again.
She would have a lot of patients and she would be understanding and she would
work very hard.
But after like three,
four months being in the gym,
I gave her maybe a few pointers and then when they call me he said it was,
they called me literally the day of the,
the day that they got her an amateur fight.
So they called me and manager called me and was like,
hey,
we got fight for Ronda and you know,
are you in the area you think you could come through?
I just honor what hit me.
But I was like,
maybe I should respect this girl.
You know,
she's a Olympic medalist and everybody's talking about Rhonda is a Olympic
medalist,
you know,
she's,
she's a cool girl,
this and that.
Manny and I was like,
maybe I should go check this girl out.
I went to the locker room,
I wrapped her and she will,
I saw,
she was excited that I was there,
you know,
I wrapped her hands and I said,
hey,
keep your hands up.
You know,
and she,
I remember she was so squared instead of being in an ag goes and I'm like,
okay.
Yeah,
like yeah,
yeah.
And then I was like,
you know,
she's going to kick you.
Doesn't matter.
Kick,
punch,
whatever comes,
just keep your hands up high and let's just step forward right away,
you know,
break the distance and get inside a clinch and do what you're best at.
And right when I told her that her focus,
the way she looked at me and you know,
I knew that she was a fighter,
but I was like,
let me let her,
let her,
let her get in there first.
You know what I mean?
It was till I see this girl.
Yes,
I could see it.
Speed,
power,
explosiveness without even having that top level of training.
The way she did it and I knew she was a real athlete,
real fighter shawls.
I was coming back down.
I text the manager,
I was like,
give me the name and last name of this girl,
spell it out for me.
Because I didn't,
I didn't.
But yeah,
besides that,
I didn't even speak English well,
so how could I write it like that?
But they're so he,
he texted it to me.
I didn't look that day.
Next Day was like maybe 3:00 PM I went online and I pressed her name that it
came amateur debut around the Rousey and it had already like 100,000 views.
I was like,
what the hell just happened,
you know,
we just fought,
how is that possible?
A hundred thousand years.
And I was like,
okay,
this girl has a falling.
Then I started looking at her judo fights,
all their matches.
And it was interesting.
I knew that she was a real fighter because of her attitude,
her approach to fighting.
And you know,
I don't understand judo at that point and especially that end,
understand much about it.
But you know,
I have a vision.
I've done all kinds of martial arts growing up and I knew what's a technical
fighter only?
What's a fighter that has the attitude to fight?
What's a fighter that's born to fight?
You know,
so she had all the pluses,
but I knew that it could be way better done.
Why?
Because right away I knew that,
hey,
USA judo,
you know,
it's amazing when Anna Marie did with Ronda Rousey is phenomenal.
What being in this country would,
you know,
judo not being such a strong sport and United States and all the gyms she took
her to and all that guidance major into something special.
It's an amazing job then.
But I said it could be done,
you know,
boxing and it's in
in u s boxing.
Xiu Jen.
I said,
if we train what that concept and keep her judo,
there's girls who are going to be unreal.
Just started working with her.
It was amazing.
No,
no,
no.
Then we bumped heads.
Yeah.
You want to say
she?
She said she just started working with her.
No,
I didn't.
No.
Three amateur fights.
I remember going home.
I remember going home to,
to,
to my acts,
he was my boyfriend at the time and just
bitching about how Edmund would not spend any time on me at all.
Even though even though,
yeah,
we already had a blow and he was,
he was spending
every night,
oh go home every night.
And I'd be like,
he's still,
you know,
I'm there and Asca and he's just like,
I don't know.
He's playing hard to get or like playing hard to get and he's like,
Hey,
all essentially almost intentionally rubbing my base and he's not paying
attention.
Me.
And like,
oh my God,
they turned the corner.
It was before my first pro fight.
He started,
um,
actually I had a rider,
this how it happened.
She says it a bit different talking to this thing,
she says it a bit differently,
but this is what happened.
I was wearing,
I don't know what kind of shirt was I wearing,
but this was before the first amateur fight.
We had this fight.
Yeah,
yeah.
You tell it.
Yeah.
I was wearing like a shirt and my fighter had another pound or two pounds to
drop.
He was fighting on showtime.
I did a boxer and he was on the elliptical just to break into a quick and she
came right in front of me when I got out of the locker room and I was Nah
early that morning so I can go to Alberta Cranes,
uh,
Jim and spar,
they did MMA
borrowing in the morning like eight 30 to like whatever,
nine 30.
Um,
well they are like eight 30 to 10.
They had a workout,
but I left early at nine 30 so that I could get to the gym in time at 10 to be
able to be there to,
to bug admin and to heal holding him.
It's for me because he wasn't,
uh,
he still hadn't at that point.
But everyday Howard aspect can hold this to me.
He's like non Betsy how I miss me and how I got this thing.
It's being does and every single day,
like the excuse got like worse and worse and worse.
And I have an excuse me.
Yeah.
And so that day I left sparring early so that I could be there.
I'm like my hands,
I'm sitting behind the desk,
I'm all like,
okay.
He's like,
I'm gonna like pretty much right when it gets in the door,
I'm gonna ask him again cause that's like my thing now.
Right.
And um,
he comes to the door and I'm like,
Hey man,
can you let Mr me today?
And he goes,
I don't want to sweat in this shirt.
Yeah.
Like that.
I will do.
I want,
this is fucking bullshit.
She started like,
we were always got open,
no
letters.
It was like,
it was like he pulled the record,
I was like,
oh
my God,
something's going to happen.
And it was just like,
I can't,
yeah.
So then like I like I walk up and I'm like going to grab my stuff or whatever
and I'm walking back across.
He's like,
don't ever leave.
don't ever swear him.
No.
Ever speak to me like that in my gym.
And I was like,
and I was like,
fuck it,
whatever.
And then like left,
went out the door,
I grabbed all my stuff,
I was ready to never go back in there again.
Like I was like,
well I'm not welcome back anymore.
He never even said that I could train there.
He just didn't say,
no,
you have to leave.
So I just stayed is not a welcoming environment.
No.
And then pulling away,
I was like,
Oh God,
I left my gloves,
you know,
cause I couldn't afford anything.
Those are gloves that were given to me.
I think Roman gave me in gloves and I was like off,
you know,
like whatever,
find new gloves,
I'll find a gym.
I don't know how I'm afford any of it.
I don't even know how influenced gets home.
But somehow,
and then like,
then he uh,
texted me to come back.
He like,
I got a text,
it was like come back to the gym and I was like,
well at least I can get my gloves and have excuse,
walked back in and grab my gloves.
So I turned back around and go back to the gym.
You can pick it up from here if you want.
And then when I said I need to talk to you,
could you drop me off at the bank?
I got to make some deposits.
And she said yeah,
she was with the Honda and I sit in the car.
I was like,
holy fuck,
I can't move in here.
Cause it was all messy on the receipt
cation in change to make rent.
Okay.
If it's that close every month,
a car wash.
Okay.
What it means free car wash.
And so like also had a dog that like,
I had a really small apartment,
I saw his dog Mochi,
she's awesome.
But like she was like crate train for the car pretty much.
You know like I would bring her everywhere I could but like not at the gym
because she wasn't allowed at the gym.
But I'm just showing your car.
Yeah.
If I like had to go anywhere,
you know,
like in the evening I wasn't gonna let her like die of heat stroke or anything.
If it was like the weather was fine,
she would come with me everywhere.
And then like I had a basket system in my car where I had like I would just
bring my basket of clean clothes and put it next to an empty basket and then
after training I would put all the other clothes and all the dirty clothes in
one basket.
And then when the clean clothes basket was empty,
I'd wash the other one and like had this rotating basket thing.
My dog is just obsessed with the smell of my vagina.
I don't know why.
I don't know why,
but she would just go through all that she owns.
She,
whenever she was in the back,
she had rip all of the dirty clothes out.
What?
I'm all over the chair,
just rub my old sweaty underwear.
I'd been sitting in there like just all over her face.
Like it was like her favorite thing in the world.
And so it's just,
there's just this sweaty pants,
underwear and bras everywhere and dog hair and all this stuff.
And men is like both CD clean.
You want to know why that pen is straight?
Because he's probably like that earlier and he already went like that and
straightened it out and we just didn't realize it.
Okay.
So he gets in my car and my car,
it looks like,
you know,
it is a petri just strike trying to find it like the new Kia for like leprosy or
something.
And he like levitated like hovering inside the car,
like a public [inaudible] possible is a really low ride.
You know,
you somehow had his feet like at a 45 degree angle but was not touching his ass
to my chair.
And that's how I drove him to.
And did you guys resolve it in the car?
And I told her that I was thinking about my fighters sweating.
Right.
But it wasn't a great excuse.
[inaudible] did is he explained why he was right.
It
was cutting weight and this is my way
there I,
in my mind I was like,
there will be a time that you will be in the same position.
I have to be next to you because I'm a like a,
but you obviously felt bad about it
or,
yeah.
So I said come back and then,
but in my mind when I was,
when I told her to come back,
I was like,
man,
this girl is really wants to
fucking do it.
And this was at a time where the UFC didn't have women's fights.
Women's fights were an oddity at other than the Gina Carano Cyborg fight.
There was very little attention whatsoever given to women's fighting.
So for you it was like this thing that wasn't like a promising proposition.
Exactly.
But I never,
never,
no,
I didn't think about that.
I like to keep it real,
honestly.
Like she sees a lot of athletes come right now to my gym even.
I tried to help them,
guide them.
You know,
I never think about she knows about finances or will they become something
special.
I want to help all of them out,
you know?
But at a point in life,
you know,
you have to make sacrifices and understand
what you're doing.
If fascinating position to be a coach because a coach realize a hundred percent
on having a quality student.
If you're,
if you're a great coach and you are around people that don't give a fuck and
don't train hard and don't care,
your knowledge is like,
it's,
it doesn't ever get to them.
It doesn't ever get out there and no one could ever see what you're truly good
at.
And you and I had this conversation once after her fight and uh,
you were saying that all my years of training fighters,
who would have ever thought that it would be this woman that would be like the
greatest student
man.
He couldn't stand him.
He didn't like doing it,
man.
He likes trains,
train Manny just because like,
man,
he works so hard.
He's Armenian,
Mike Round fight.
I train men
and all those fight,
but
well the Mike Brown fight was wanting him,
knocked him out with him and then all of those,
there was a huge win for him.
Yeah.
But yeah,
other than that,
admin only had men,
Armenian boxers and that was like his little like soap category.
How
relationship work as far as like you are the striking coach then,
but you're her overall coach.
Yes.
I give the whole program and I say when we're grappling one I'm doing using her
judo know when to use the judo,
like speed week,
when to bring in those sparring partners.
What kind of sparring partners,
how many days a week she does her strength and conditioning where sparrings you
know,
but she's boxing and strength and conditioning.
So she's learning doorways but I see Henner in your corner occasionally.
Edmund does like the structure of the camp.
So what we do what days,
but when I do like you know,
Jitsu,
judo,
wrestling,
you know I'm working with somebody else because like the amount of time or you
know how like how the intensity or what day it is.
Is that,
that we're working on specific,
you know,
pony or bike her too.
Because you're the closest to her.
Exactly.
I know her mentally what she needs to do to to be dominant.
No.
So sometimes people that don't have so much experience,
they will work on certain things during certain time of the training camp that
it's unnecessary to work on that,
you know,
because you could do that at times that when she's off off,
uh,
she doesn't have a training camp,
she doesn't have a fight.
So I understand that's why sometimes it was so difficult to teach her everything
in boxing and to progress earlier.
The reason was Rhonda could have done that is because we had fights in front of
us.
So when we have fights in front of us,
we specifically work on that opponent and when she needs to do,
I didn't show her how to throw an overhand right or anything like that until the
Alexis Davis fight.
She knocked her out,
you know,
I told her straight shots.
Those are the best for you to back them up.
Get that clinch,
you know,
you don't want those big overhead shots.
And we could stop all of those with what a Great Jab.
You know,
you work your way inside with a jab in boxing.
You work your way out.
If you don't want anybody to come inside,
you keep that job out there and they kicked,
they will have a hard time.
So it's simple concept.
A lot of footwork,
you know,
utilizing the distance.
Right.
And you see how she gets to clinch,
you know,
if you watch um,
Liz's fight,
short,
stocky girl throwing heart short shots,
the way she maneuvers and uses that Jab kits on that elbow,
it's,
it's beautiful.
For you.
Was it a difficult transition becoming an MMA coach?
Like being in a situation where was a people that don't know?
I was,
I did,
I have like 40 professional Muay Thai fights,
you know,
after doing,
we tied the shoot boxing.
I fought in Japan throws,
so I was used to all that.
I did taekwondo matches,
all those international,
Jimmy came all those fights.
So I have experienced and all kinds of martial arts.
But then fell in love with boxing,
you know,
polished my hands and you know,
trained with the best and putting it all together.
It's not,
it's a fight is a fight.
Right.
You've got to understand what the,
it's not only about the fight,
you got to understand what you have as a trainer.
I ain't know what I have.
I know what ability she has.
And you know,
uh,
I know around this personality,
I know what they're going to be trying to do.
This last fight,
she knows,
I said,
Rhonda,
the way you're punching,
right,
not everybody's going to try to push you off them or they're going to be
desperate for them to clinch before you would want to go clinch,
but now you're going to clip them so hard.
Guess what?
They're gonna try to come in,
clinch you.
And when they're doing that,
you either counter take down,
which you can do or you from,
keep on punching them counter punch or you know,
push him off,
knock their ass out.
What happened?
She was punching her with that you want to do,
she couldn't take those shots.
She came to grab around the,
around the push.
They're neater.
Jumped on her again.
Fight was over.
So,
but that we understood as we're seeing progress because when I'm seeing the
spying partners,
we have a boxing world champion spying would run,
the run is on her hitting here and this goes like holy shit.
Trying to get insight to close tie her up.
It means it's a big problem.
So are you,
are you analyzing this stuff independently of your transactions?
We absolutely sitting down afterwards and you're going over what that's like
teach group classes.
I can't do group.
I like to work on an individual's ability and bring out the best from the
fighter.
You got to look deep into exactly too much too much yet should I put I,
I,
you know,
and doing it at this level,
you have to have that fighter,
you have to love that fighter.
You have to care about that fighter.
You have to understand that fighter personality.
So you know,
that's why she puts me to under the seat,
lets me write the whole structure,
but I'll tell you,
she is an intelligent why?
Because there hasn't been choices.
She's made or said,
hey coach,
you know,
we should go work with Henner and hit on,
because just to understand their tactical approach to fighting where they're on
their back.
I will never write lie down on my back,
you know.
But getting it was like he did all the striking and I was all of the grappling
and then I didn't have a Jujitsu or wrestling coach for years.
And then I brought Martin Barbarian,
what's an Olympic with a three time Olympian,
bronze medalist,
you know,
so we added like I added once she added Henry and hit on and she was like,
just for a minute.
Yeah.
To understand the approach to their style.
And then now when we go,
she understands that when they're on their back and being passive,
she judo Kai's not going to lie down on their back.
Kids who don't know you lose that way.
So,
but they do their,
you know,
Jujutsu doesn't just for her to be aware of that.
And I said,
Rhonda,
you're brilliant.
Let's go to them and we'll do it once a week,
twice a week.
So you could understand their approach to,
you know,
grappling and then we'll know how to take advantage of that.
Well,
it's a ever evolving game.
Grappling unlike anything else is constantly evolving and adding new techniques
to it and like have you paid attention to Abu Dhabi?
Like the world championships?
It's all leg locks now.
It's crazy.
There's so the leg lock game and grappling has changed so much over the last few
years.
Everybody's attacking with leg locks,
using leg locks for sweeps using establish other transitions.
When you bring striking into it is it's very different because it's very risky
in that when you go for a leg lock up doesn't work out,
you lose position.
I May,
yeah,
I don't think a lot more about about risk and that's why I feel like like,
uh,
armbars works so well is because if it doesn't work out,
I'm still,
I'm still on top.
I could still
be somewhere positive,
you know,
instead of if I go for a leg lock,
I'm suddenly on the bottom,
you know?
That's why I don't do doubles.
I don't shoot it for devil's is what if it doesn't work?
Then you're on the bottom here in the worst year in a worst place.
It's so risky.
Do you know what Eddie Commons is?
Top Level Brazilian Jujitsu competitor right now trains other John Danaher and
John Danaher apparently has a very complex and comprehensive system involving
attacking legs and leg locks.
He's one of Hanzo Gracie's black belts,
really,
really respected Jujitsu guy.
And uh,
Eddie was talking about uh,
he was,
he just competed in Abu Dhabi and he was talking about bringing leg locks to MMA
and that you are seeing many more leg locks in MMA now because guys are learning
the like at the highest level that the transitions,
it's like a lot of times we have these looks at things and we go,
well that's not going to work because of this.
And people might have said that about all sorts of different aspects of MMA
before someone came along and figured out a way to do it successfully.
I think we're kind of seeing that as counting like leg locks,
the risky.
And then again,
I said there is the ability of the fighter would have built you have you what
you've done,
like you know what I'm saying?
Like when she does Henry and hit on and you know,
during training camp she's not going to one month before to fight,
lie down on her back and try to do triangles.
Right.
That's not her.
You know what I mean?
So we need to be dominant in certain areas.
Do you train
those things like,
like do you learn like specific skills outside of a training camp?
So like when training camp's over,
you know,
you knock out Batchko hey a and you go,
ah,
I'd like to learn how to do this.
Or I'd like to add a little bit of that.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's just,
do you learn stuff for a particular direction when you're outside of camp and
camp is what directs it towards something specific.
But is it crazy because MMA,
there's so many skills,
there's so many things you get adhere to or so many styles you get.
It's like you had Kinda kinda figure out where to focus your thing and you're,
you're focusing your thing on boxing.
You're judo and your arm bar and because of that it's,
you've been so successful because everything is just razor sharp.
When you start adding things,
sometimes what happens is you're putting too much attention to these other
things you can add.
But no,
went wet.
That's the thing.
No one that we got Justin floors,
you know,
he comes into judo,
the explosive throws.
We know that judo is all about timing and explosive and she loves it when she
uses that,
knowing when to do that,
you know what I mean?
But if she does that right now when we're just starting off and quick explosive
throws,
her body's not ready.
Like you were saying about strength and conditioning,
people do that so they could prevent injuries,
right.
For you not to have your joints hurting this.
And that's why it's the same thing.
You have to think of it when to use it.
It's okay to add,
but when to use it,
when you're fighting,
you have to do what's best of your ability to get the w.
It's about the w.
It's not what you make the mistake of trying to memorize certain things like
separate things that aren't completely disjointed and not related as opposed to
memorizing concepts.
Like when when I'm grappling,
I probably make up 15 different moves a night that I've never done before just
off the top of my head because it makes sense,
right?
Cause you know the concept and now that you're in an unusual position you just
apply the concept and that concept.
So I'm just applying the concepts to every kind of situation I could end up and
I don't memorize every single individual move it,
it doesn't make sense.
I'm not going to memorize a leg lock and then memorize a spinning back elbow and
then memorize a push kick and memorize.
You know,
something else is completely a superman punch like that.
They're completely all over the place and they have nothing to do with each
other and not connected.
Why am I spending so many hours of my day on all these different things,
right.
That they,
they're not connected to each other and so I spend a lot of my time connecting
things as opposed to trying to learn individual things that don't have any kind
of thing.
Yeah.
Their ring generalship where's the ring?
Generalship is the most important thing.
You see her on the pads.
Watch your,
every time I'm stepping,
she's one step ahead.
She's,
what is she doing?
She's controlling me.
She is controlling you and she's exactly are we building the framework?
The most important thing in boxing and fighting in general,
you can be in the middle of doc,
gone walk 10 steps and hit your back on the cage and then expect to learn a
superman punch and become something special.
You got to learn your ring generalship first.
There's more to fighting people just,
you know.
No,
I'd have an idea and there's coaches out there that think,
oh,
they could show a fancy jumping kick or a punch or whatever it is,
or a throw and become something special with that.
No,
no,
it doesn't work that way.
Positioning is so critical and grappling,
but it's just as critical and striking.
It's just in critical,
just as critical and movement,
just as critical and being in a position where the person literally doesn't have
the leverage to hit you correctly and that,
so it's an art and you watch Floyd Mayweather and so one thing he does better
than anybody,
he's always in pajamas position exact,
constantly in a good position to avoid damage.
Always.
If he goes on the ring,
ropes calls you ans takes the impact.
He knows which round he's doing that in.
You know,
if he knows you're a huge puncher,
he won't go there the first two rounds,
he'll you know know exactly when he's calling you in to counter those shots.
You know on the ring ropes on the ropes,
he knows when to do it.
It's about when to do it,
how I use it.
When Rhonda went and clinched Misha in all the second fight around,
this says she was done and then Michigan mid that she was hurt from that right
hand.
If you watch your interview at the end,
she's like,
yeah,
I got here,
died.
That was a good right hand.
Right.
Well it made sense because she was so high.
She was so high up on your hips.
Oh I remember watching.
I was like,
why is she,
she's going flying Chabot.
Yeah,
but as soon as she was clenching you up high like that,
I was like,
but it's the sense when Rhonda says I clinched her,
she was already out right around the toss third and did an arm bar.
But why she did that throw there is because she knew she was out.
Right.
She could have finished it spending whatsoever
allows the,
the beginning,
the third round and I,
she was out on her feet.
It's a straight right.
And I knew it because of the way she was breathing.
When I put her up against the cage,
I felt she was,
she was deflated and she wasn't there anymore.
So I knew I could do whatever kind of bullshit throw in the world.
Even I could be on the bottom.
It's still gonna be still going to work right then cause she's not there.
And the idea not fight the,
the structure of the fight that he put out is you're going to break her first
standing and then the submission will be easier because they're going to be so
focused on the submission.
You have to get them their mind somewhere else before you go for it and so at
that point I,
I knew that she wasn't there because of like you have to have a feel for the
other person and know them very well.
You get to know them so intimately.
You know that if they're breathing differently,
you know where their mind is at and that's the time I can,
I can do the shitty assuming guy sheet that you ever seen and be straight on the
bottom and know that I'm going to finish it from there because she's not
defensively there at all.
When you,
when you're looking at your future right now,
are you,
are you planning like when you're going to bail out of this and what your life
is going to be like after,
because you've,
you've hit this crazy peak in your life right now that it's likely never going
to be replicated by anyone else that comes after you.
You're in this weird crazy position and it can't last.
It may even,
you can't fight like this when you're 80 you just,
it just can't be done.
So you're not going to be
doing this in my thirties no,
no,
not when you're 30 no,
not really.
I don't want to be fighting in my third.
Dana White's going to call you up on the phone and he's going to listen fucker,
my captain D's.
I mean like 31 32 stacks of thousands is going to rifle it through the phone
by me.
If you're actually 30 years old,
that's not thirties that's 30 thirty's that's thirties plural.
How old are you now?
28 28 are you really thinking like a couple of years,
two,
three years.
Like what are you thinking?
I don't know.
Like I look at it like,
like exactly
how we were talking about how fighting,
that's how I do everything else.
I don't look at all these separate disjointed things like I'm not going to go in
there and I'm not going to try this thing and then try this thing and try that
thing and then hope something works out.
It's like I follow like,
like a path train of thought while I'm in,
I'm in there and while I'm doing everything else.
So it's just like this is what I want to do right now and these are the possible
reactions,
these possible things that could happen and we're going with option three.
Okay,
this is,
these are the possible ray and I and I follow it like,
like,
like a path from whatever happened from what I'm doing right now that determines
everything else afterward.
And I just kind of follow it.
And so it's very,
everything's very organically done and I'm improvising all the time.
I'm improvising on,
I'm fighting,
I'm free,
I'm improvising with my career.
I just know the concepts of what I want to accomplish in my career.
I don't know exactly what I'm going to be doing.
I don't walk in and know I'm going to arm bar that person.
You know?
I don't right now know exactly what I'm going to win.
I'm going to retire and how exactly I want to do it,
but I
know what's going to happen at some point.
I know I'm going to be undefeated,
I want to be undefeated.
I know and I'm going to retire at some point,
but still I'm still so far away that I can't say exactly how I'm still following
the path and the train of thought to get there.
And we know when she wins.
You know wood so quick.
No injuries,
training,
healthy,
happy,
smart,
intelligent.
Back to back wins.
We should get fight three fights a year,
you know,
because Wu shoes in there,
not over a minute for this last three fights,
how are you going to know when to stop and what,
what do you think you'll be able to just walk away?
Yeah,
but that's why I look at fader.
Ah,
that's what I'm doing.
All this other back to Dick's because what else is there for them to do?
So using the other stuff will be sufficient and sufficiently exciting.
Yeah,
I just want to build it up and nothing to tell but enough where it's ready for
me to do full time when I want to switch over,
you know,
I,
I got a lot going on do I?
We're lucky you almost have too much going on.
Well,
you know,
I was wonder,
you're doing movies right before your training for fights in the middle of
things.
And it's hard like doing expendables and fast and furious back to back right
before going into cow.
Right.
Tell him why it went to the third round with Misha.
Joe knows,
you know,
you know why it went to the third round.
Why not only that,
but I still keep us saying it is because she had the movies,
right.
So first time going to a big movie or career and dealing with all those big
actors and she kept her weight very low and she,
I wasn't there because I had known Etos and Vic's fight don't fight and I
couldn't go there to help her out during training camp when she came back around
the,
you know because she always,
I do her hand wraps and she works on the bag in her hands.
I don't know how to wrap my own hand.
Her hands are ready to take that impact.
She messed up her knuckles right away during training camp.
She was in fit,
you know she was healthy and it took us,
she,
she couldn't throw punches that fight.
You still hurt her in the third round.
That's why when I the the other one we thought we were going to fight and show
the next fed.
I said it's not healthy for her.
It's not going to be healthy for a mission next time she fights around that,
you know,
this,
this scar on my knuckle,
the,
I think it was like nine stitchers or something like that from the Alexis Davis
fight.
That is an injury from that mission fight because I lost my cows as while I was
filming.
And so,
um,
when I came back all the skin came off my hands right away.
Like bear,
like my knuckles were like gone.
While you were filming,
you didn't do any training at all?
No,
I trained a lot,
but I couldn't do any impact on my hands because I punched you high for my
hands.
I have the smallest hands in the UFC.
You have tiny,
fragile little hands.
Like even like my thumb bone like is like,
it's so small.
Yeah.
And um,
so I,
I can't hit unless he professionally routes my hands with gauze and tape every
single training session.
I can't hit any other way.
My hands will like explode pretty much.
And so I was training really hard.
I was running up mountains and I was wrestling and I was,
you know,
doing all these things and um,
everything that I could,
but I wasn't having any impact on my hands.
I was shadow boxing with the ways I was doing everything I could.
But yeah,
I couldn't land anything.
And so I got home and all the skin comes off my hands then,
but I'm like,
okay,
I have to leave for fashion for years and a few days,
so fuck it.
I'm just gonna just gonna Punch like this.
And so it was just open wounds.
I was punching open wounds for five days straight until I,
like,
I literally had a crater like on this one hand and I'm just like,
okay,
well it'll heal on that fast,
furious and I'll come back,
I'll be fine because me,
I'm like,
you know,
I'm thinking,
Oh,
she just scraped whatever and then I come back and it never heals the whole
camp.
We just keep putting neosporin and peroxide in it and I just have like,
like a crater in my hand and it keeps falling off and the whole thing falls off
and it gets bigger every time.
Every time it falls off,
it's bigger and it's deeper.
And I started to see like the little,
like the fat,
like beads because it's like that like deep,
like I would look at it sideways and there would be a dent inside and then it
would heal and then there'd be a huge lump and then they would whatever it was
inside of versus I was getting a ganglion cyst on my knuckle is what it was.
And um,
so I finally like,
he healed up enough where I could fight,
you know,
like,
but I had to like not punch on it really at all.
What else would rip right off?
And I remember right before I,
if I had told the admin and I was like,
this knuckle on my right hand,
I'm like,
fucking,
I'm going to plant it round face.
And I'm like,
and that's why I ended up actually knocking out with the straight.
Right.
But then I had,
I couldn't get anything done about it.
Um,
because then I had to go straight to McMahon.
And then real quick man,
I did two cans back to back.
Now my knee is fucking up because I'm doing two camps back to back and I can't
take that much punishment all the time.
And my knuckle is like still like super fucked up and I'm like whatever.
And it keeps ripping off and Co and trying to heal it back and ripping off and
try and hit it back and ripping off and trying to heal it back.
And um,
so we get through the big man fight hand.
I was going to get surgery,
I was going to get my hand and my knee worked on.
But then Dana was like,
listen,
you can fight Gina in February,
in February,
in December.
And I was like,
well I don't want to wait until December.
I want it.
I'll be a better fighter in December if I fight in July.
I don't want to be sitting ring rust that long cause covering rusted for the
Meesha fight.
I didn't feel good.
So I'm like,
I want,
I want to stay active and that time,
so like give me a fight right away.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to fight.
Um,
Alexis Davis is just like,
I just wanna find someone.
So I was like,
Alexis Davis,
you said Gina.
Yeah,
it was going to be Gina Carano and it ended up not happening.
But um,
so that was a big deal.
Yeah.
So I wanted to fight in the,
so I was like,
okay,
can't get surgery and I can't get all these things weren't on.
Now I'm gonna go to this fight and they'll do it afterward.
And so then I went and did the Lexus fight and I remember just looking at this
thing and my knuckle hall,
I was like,
I feel like I could pull it out.
Like I feel like whatever the fuck is in there,
I could get it out.
And there were times I was trying to do surgery on it and like pull things out
and I was pulling things out of my hand.
But what were you pulling out of their financial beads?
Like little balls of things.
I don't know what they were like.
I felt like I was flying with pulling out like balls of fat or scar tissue and
stuff like out of my hand and I'm Jesus.
But I felt like,
like even right before the Davis fight,
I was like,
I feel like I could just rip it off right now and pull it out.
But I couldn't do it because I was about to fight and I couldn't do that to my
hand,
but I just,
I just want it.
I just couldn't wait to get this thing out.
I felt like it was in there.
I was like itchy almost.
And then,
yeah,
the first overran handwrite ever threw in a fight.
I throw it right on Alexis,
his head and the whole thing exploded like down to the bone,
like from the inside of my uncle all the way out.
They never got good footage of it because I didn't want my mom to see it cause
she was like all,
you know,
uh,
really nervous and worried for me when I'm doing MMA.
And so there's like this tiny bit of footage to Elliott got where I'm like
holding my hand away from my mother and he's like looking around the corner,
which then sees like you never saw it.
It was down to the bone all the way around my hand and the whole thing blew up.
We saw the rap,
the rap is covered in blood when it fine,
but that's how you get rid of the ganglion cyst.
You have to like burst it.
And so it was actually gone once we did that and less soda and then as I was
like,
oh cool.
You know,
that's what,
that's what it was.
I thought my hand here.
And then I realized a couple days later I broke my phone and I was like walking
around like with my hand out and I ended up having to have a pin put in and like
all that stuff.
So like I just had fragile little hands.
I have a great chin but five's a little hands.
Yeah.
I'd rather have it that way than the other way around.
But yeah,
so that's,
that's my,
my knuckle chronicle.
And then I ripped it open before the last camp because of this stupid,
was it commercial now?
The Promo commercial and then I hurt my pinky during the Budweiser commercial.
I didn't hurt anything else during the,
the camp at all.
I got hurt doing like the two like commercials right beforehand is one of the
big problems that people don't think about when they watch fights.
If they're a casual observers,
the sword fighters are going into camp with [inaudible].
You know,
we do it,
but she punches.
It's,
it's natural.
It's normal.
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta take my kid to a martial arts class.
I did.
I have a million things to do.
I just didn't want to know what time it was.
I was like three,
three,
10 top shit.
I'm so late for everything.
[inaudible] six three Oh six.
Okay.
Uh,
thank you.
Thanks so much.
Funding.
Anytime you guys want to come back.
Open invitation.
Thank you.
Start this bitch.
We can go off tangents is like none other really fun.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you.
Thank you for you guys.
The best thing.
One of your thing when you're a kid.